I was like, wait, wait a minute, I'm muted.
Hello everyone!
Oh my god, chat is cut out as well.
Guys, I'm so professional.
I didn't know.
Okay, give me a sec.
I gotta fix chat.
Give me a sec.
You're cut off a little.
Let me fix you guys.
There we go.
Hello everyone!
Alright, today I'm gonna be showing you guys...
I made a little playlist for you guys.
It's like back in the day when people make mixtapes and be like, please listen to my mixtape.
I made a little video.
I made a little, like, video playlist and I'm like, please watch my playlist.
Please.
I made this special Dragoon playlist.
Well, to be fair, this was my playlist.
I'll be like, that's funny and then I save it.
But then I'm like, this is my Doki playlist for the Dragoons.
So please watch my playlist.
The very important videos.
But welcome, welcome!
Welcome to my React channel that's on Twitch because I don't want to get in trouble with YouTube.
I'm now trying to re...
Some people were asking me, were like, oh, are you gonna re-upload this?
And I'm just like, I mean, I can try.
I don't...
Don't...
I'll see what's gonna happen when I re-upload it on, like, if I, like, upload the VOD on, like, on my VOD's channel and just see what happens to it.
So, like, you know, I can try.
See?
That's the worst...
I mean, it's just... I have three strikes, right?
So, like, if I get striked, at least I'll have two more strikes, you know?
Like, the first strike is just to test it out and see...
see what happens, you know?
At least not the main channel.
And technically, if you think about it, that means I have two channels.
So, like, that means I can have six strikes.
So, like, the more channels I get, the more chances I can have.
So, like, maybe I should just create another channel in case the VOD channels get a strike and I'll have another channel and that's, like, a whole new... three more strikes that I have.
Like, three more chances.
The five-minute move.
The strike leveling algorithm.
But welcome!
Welcome to my Twitch, everybody.
It's not gonna be, like, a...
I think, like, I'm not gonna be doing this a lot, obviously.
It's just, like, a special day today.
I just was... I wanted to be, like, let me show you my... I can finally, like, show you some videos that I've been, like, wanting to show you guys for a while now.
Because in the past, we had to, like, ask individually the channels to be, like, can I react to your videos?
Can I show your videos?
And they'll either not respond or just...
I don't know.
I guess not respond.
Thank
you!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much!
I almost forgot I was partnered on this... on my Twitch, guys.
It's been a while.
It's been a...
I usually use my... I realized when I was, like, setting things up on my Twitch channel I was, like, wow!
I was... I did not set up anything on my... I did not really set up anything for, like, solo streams on Twitch.
Because every time I streamed on Twitch, it's either for, like, Twitch rivals or...
Okay, it's usually for Twitch rivals.
So then when I was, like, setting everything up, I was, like, oh my god!
There's no, like... I don't know how...
I don't have any, like... By the way, By the way, I was like, wait, sorry if there's no alerts, because I'm scared of putting my alerts up right now, because I don't think... wait, I think I did mute it.
Let me see if I can... I'll put the Twitch alerts, because I was like, oh man, I don't know if I have... let me see.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, here we go.
That's good.
Okay, that's a good sign.
Alright, Twitch alerts are... I think Twitch alerts are muted.
I think.
So, that's why I was a little scared, because I didn't even, like, adjust my Twitch alerts, because I was like, oh no, is our alerts muted?
I don't know.
I haven't really figured it out yet.
Johnny Lacombe, thank you for 20 gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, Bacon, thank you for the 50 gifted subs.
I really appreciate it, guys.
Thank you so much.
I bet I'm, like, Twitch's favorite streamer, because I don't use up their bandwidth, but, like, I still have subs, so I'm, like...
They're like, give Toki Prite, dude.
She doesn't use up our bandwidth, but she still has people giving her money on Twitch.
Super cost-effective.
Yeah.
We're gonna have to resize this alert.
Holy shit.
Alright, I'll play around with it one day.
And I realized, I was like, oh shit, I didn't even upload any, like, new emotes in here.
I'm so fucked, man.
I am so...
But, yes, I don't know if, like, Soundguy is alive, because, like, Soundguy, if you're here, I need you to message me on Discord, because your messages are gonna get drowned out in the regular.
Because I haven't, like, customized my chat in a way that I can see, like...
I can see mods easier.
I haven't done that yet.
There's a lot of things I haven't done.
You guys are gonna figure it out.
There's a lot...
There's multiple things that I haven't done, guys.
Okay.
Anyway.
Also, another update.
Also, another update for you guys.
You remember how I said, like, oh, next week, I'm going to have a rest week?
Well, about that...
About that, it might not be a rest week anymore, because I sort of, like, said yes to a lot of things.
And I looked at my calendar, and I was like, oh, it's this week.
I was just like...
I'm sorry.
I was like...
Wait a minute.
They're off for, like, next week.
Oh, no.
I couldn't help it.
Okay.
When you find out what they are, they're pretty exciting.
It's pretty exciting things.
Okay.
To be fair, this entire month...
Month of May, I'm so fucked.
I'm actually...
The month of May, I sort of...
I messed up a little bit for the month of May, because I said yes to a lot of things.
And then I looked at my calendar, and I was like, oh, at one point, there's going to be, like, a back-to-back event for one of the days.
And I was like, oh, no.
But, like, I'm getting my name out there.
Yahoo.
No rest for content creators.
Let's fucking go.
All right.
Thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you.
Anyway, guys, let me show you guys the first video.
If it's, like, let me know if it's, like, too late.
I haven't figured out my Twitch Rivals team yet, by the way.
I saw, like...
So, basically, like, okay, so, like, there's, like, how I figure...
Like, every time I would, like, so go on, like, there's a Twitch Rivals schedule, and I look at it ever so often.
And then if there's something that interests me, I just press express interest.
Okay.
And then, like, my Twitch guy would message me.
I was, like, oh, we saw you express interest for this.
Do you actually want to do it?
And I'll be, like, yeah.
Yeah, sure.
Like, you want to be captain?
I'll be, like, oh, yeah, sure.
So, now I have to figure out my teammates, because I haven't really figured out my teammates yet.
There's, like, not just this Twitch Rivals.
I'm in another Twitch Rivals in two weeks.
Two weeks as well.
Because I'll be, like, I'll just be, like, do you want to do this?
I'll be, like, yeah, sure.
And then my DMs will be, like, do you want to participate in this tournament?
I'll be, like, oh, cool.
Yeah, sure.
And then I'll be, like, do you want to do this?
Oh, that's cool.
That's pretty cool.
Yeah, sure.
And then I look at my calendar, and it's, like, tournament, tournament, event, tournament.
I'll be, like, oh.
Maybe not.
No more.
Yeah, sure.
Good.
Thank you for the rate.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
So now I'm, like, I need to stop saying, yeah, sure, to things.
And then the next day, someone's going to.
And then I say that to myself.
But then the day after, someone's going to be, like, do you want to do this?
I'm, like, yeah, sure.
Sure.
So it just never stops.
Someone let me off this wild ride.
No, not June.
Okay.
June might be a little wild, but May is very wild.
May is, like, oh.
This month is, like, oh.
All right.
I'll show you guys.
I'll show you guys the first video, guys.
All right.
So I saw this and I thought it was really funny.
There's a new crab game that's, like, Dark Souls related.
Let me know if it's too loud or not.
Bright, colorful souls like game and thought, this is too happy.
We need more dark and mysterious souls like games.
There just isn't enough out there.
They're not fellow gamer.
We have added a new feature to another crab's treasure.
Dark Souls like mode.
Yeah.
Because it's too happy.
All the vibrant colors of the game and replace it with...
I was sort of, like...
I've been wanting to play this game for a bit because, like, it's basically, like, a happier version of Dark Souls.
So...
And you play, like, a cra...
You play a crab.
So...
So it's just...
It's just a happier version of Dark Souls.
I've been wanting to try out for a bit because, like, it looks, you know, not depressing.
Anyway, they added depression mode.
And dark color scheme.
Does Krill appear too happy?
Let's remove that sparkle in his eyes in determination for adventure.
In Dark Souls like mode, Krill will become depressed.
Oh, look at him.
Not a hope in sight.
Are you feeling it now, Mr. Krabs?
If Krill's depression starts to burn your experience, Dark Souls like mode unlocks a new costume.
You might recognize it for Redacted Redacted Copyright Strike Redacted.
This costume will hide Krill's defeated face.
So we're going to mod that.
Dark Souls like mode also turns all levels into a poison swamp because it's not a real Souls-like game without one.
Look at that poiseony goodness.
We also added, Anor Londo.
Fuck it.
OK, I got- OK, I got this ad on my shorts.
I was like, is that Markiplier?
But then- OK, but then, like- OK, OK, I just need you guys to know.
I got this ad while scrolling through the chat.
I'm walking through YouTube Shorts and like the plot twist is that not only is that character based off of Markiplier, but it's furry Markiplier.
I wouldn't get any closer if I were you.
I'm not saying.
By the way, if anyone wants to download this game, feel free.
I'll bite you, but I'm not saying it either.
I was like, wait, this is like, it's a dating sim.
Instead of dating like the human versions of them, you're dating the animals?
But like, they're not, the thing is...
The thing is, they're not like...
They're actual animals.
Like, it's not even furry anymore.
They're actually animals.
And I was like, oh, this is...
I was like, wait...
That's not...
I was just like, wait a minute.
There's something...
Anyway, it's called Blush Blush.
Can somebody please play this game for me and then report back?
Can someone play this game and report back to me?
Oh, yeah.
Also, I really want to show you guys this video.
Why would we do that?
I want to show you guys this one.
This has been like...
This lives rent-free in my mind sometimes.
This video.
This is one of my favorite covers.
This was made 4 years ago.
I love Spongebob Vocaloid.
There's one with Reaper from Overwatch.
And then there's one...
There's so many of Spongebob.
And then there's like Cartman Vocaloids too.
I listen to this cover like once a year.
It's not just me.
It's not AI.
It's Vocaloid.
It's different.
You uncultured.
It's swine.
Look at him go.
Look at Squidward go.
Look at the sea crab.
He lists all the sources of videos.
Okay, Spongebob and Squidward, Vocaloid, walked.
So like, what was it?
The fucking AI rap covers could run?
Go Squidward, go!
He's so kawaii!
The covers!
Wait, you're so right!
Okay, wait, wait, wait, okay.
I don't know if you guys... Okay, I need to...
Oh my god, Plankton!
Look at him go!
You guys can't see him.
He's over there on the right.
I'm covering him up.
Have you guys seen the presidential covers?
The AI songs!
Go Plankton, go!
Okay, but like... This is like... Okay, I need to show you guys the OG.
I need you guys... I need to show you guys the OG.
We're at the OG MMD, the rabbit hole.
I think it's this one.
It has to be this one, right?
This has to be like... I think this is the OG.
This is the rabbit hole of where I...
This was seven years ago, by the way.
Look at him go!
So beautiful!
He's so kawaii!
This was... This was my rabbit hole.
My Reaper can't be this kawaii.
Nioh, thank you for the hundred pennies!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank
you!
Thank you!
My
God!
Okay, I was speaking of this... Okay, no, no, no, no, no.
Speaking of this...
Have you guys heard of the... The Toons Drag Race?
Wait, Toons of Drag Race.
Have you guys seen that?
Oh my God, wait.
Okay, I think it's this one.
What was it?
Who is Oc... Wait, who is... Cartoons Drag Race.
Okay, I... That like popped up on my Twitter feed.
And I... I...
That is so fucking stupid.
The first season of Cartoons Drag Race has...
Okay, no!
Does anyone have the actual YouTube video?
It's on TikTok!
So like, nobody has the actual car... video!
Please, re-upload it on...
Please, I'm making... I'm making YouTube channel!
Okay, Drag Race Cartoons.
Alright, let me see if I can find it.
No!
Guys, I can't react to it because nobody...
He didn't make a YouTube channel.
He didn't make a...
We're saying...
No, it's so funny though!
You don't understand!
Also, here's one with... with our boys.
Oh my...
Sorry!
Oh my God, look at his legs!
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
Look at Soldier's fucking...
You wish!
You...
That's why we call him Legs, guys!
This is exactly why we call him Legs!
I can't hear Miguel.
This is my rabbit hole.
Overwatch MMDs.
Are there people?
Other people?
They...
They watch the Overwatch...
They watch Overwatch?
Different Overwatch videos?
I watch this.
They...
They go to a different site for their Overwatch videos.
I just watch Overwatch MMDs.
Oh my God.
Oh my God!
For all that running, though.
It paid off for Soldier!
My Overwatch goes to another school.
Ah, ah, ah...
All I'm saying...
All I'm saying... is that...
is that...
I can't do this.
Okay.
All right, let me...
Oh, and then there's this one!
Oh, here's a Cartman version.
Let's see.
Where is it?
I'm trying to find the Cartman version.
Here you go.
Here's a Cartman AI.
They did like... I found... I wanted to grab a hold of these covers where like they did like various... various like cartoon characters.
Bro!
He's a natural singer!
It's a singer!
There's a lot of them, by the way.
It's not just Cartman.
There's a Peter...
Oh my god!
There's a Peter Griffin one!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Let me show you guys the Peter Griffin one.
Peter Griffin.
AI.
Oh my god.
What is it?
It was a Steven Universe song.
What is this one?
Bro!
AI goes hard!
Why do people like use AI unethically?
Why can't we do meme shit like this?
Bro!
Why can't we just do fun stuff?
Why do people have to ruin it?
Like...
It's so good!
Isn't it?
Isn't it over?
It's over.
Isn't it?
Isn't it over?
You won.
And she chose you.
And she loved you.
And she's gone.
It's over.
Isn't it?
Why can't I move on?
War and glory.
Re tile in stone 3 vaime screams.
attention out in daylight.
My potential.
My poten entered prevert experimental.
Who am I now in this world without her?
Petty and tall with her entire stomach.
Lois.
That's good for me though.
It's over, isn't it?
Isn't it?
It's over, it's over, isn't it?
Isn't it over?
You won, and she chose you, and she loved you, and she's gone!
It's over, isn't it?
Why can't I move on?
Sorry, I went into a rabbit hole.
I'm going through so many different rabbit holes right now.
I'm sorry guys, I'm getting off track.
Anyway, back to my playlist.
Anyway, back to the playlist that I fucking made for you guys.
Guess why I'm showing you guys all the fun videos I wanted to show you!
Oh, okay, wait, wait, wait.
Alright, to be fair, I'll give you guys some normal videos.
That wasn't the playlist.
No, no, no, no.
These are like videos I just went... I was like, oh my god.
I wanna... oh my god, I forgot about these videos too.
Anyway, here are like actual normal videos that I watched, by the way.
Here are some actual normal videos.
Okay, I'm gonna recommend you guys a channel that I've actually like really liked to watch ever so often.
And it's like a cooking channel.
But like, he does like cookbook reviews, but he does like gamer cookbook reviews.
And it's like really interesting.
Cause like, all... I always think like, who buys these types of cookbooks?
You know like those types of cookbooks where it's like gamer... gaming or anime or like TV show inspired.
And like, he does like those like reviews of those cookbooks.
Cause I always wonder who buys these.
Like, who the fuck...
You know, like, oh, family's visiting, let me make a...
Let me make an Assassin's Creed meal inspired.
Like...
Like dinner or something.
Yes!
It's me so hungry!
I just finished binging the Fallout TV show.
Okay, this is like actually...
I thought it really captured the unique post-apocalyptic flavor of the games.
And it got me really nostalgic.
I really enjoy watching his channel whenever he does like updates.
Honestly, I'm surprised he only has 150k subscribers.
Because like, I actually really enjoy watching his videos and stuff.
So like...
So he has like all these like...
He has like cookbook reviews and stuff.
He would be like Bob's Burgers.
The Sonic Cookbook.
And like...
Oh, like Neopets Cookbook.
Uh...
The Rick and Morty...
Let's watch the Rick and Morty one.
Hey, put me over.
Come on!
With the pickle!
Boom!
Big reveal!
I turned myself into a pickle!
I'm Pickle Miso!
Guys, you don't understand.
You don't have a high enough IQ to understand this.
Well, I hear Rick and Morty might be needing a new voice actor.
So, think of this as my audition.
Come on, Cartoon Network!
If you have any...
Alright, we're gonna skip this.
This is a little cringe.
We're taking a look at Rick and Morty.
It's a little cringe!
The Pickle Cookbook by August Bragg and James Astley.
This book takes us along Rick and Morty's adventure through space and time with a focus on the funky alien foods they come across along the way.
I really dig the way they presented this cookbook.
Basically, for Morty's home economics school project, he decided to put together a cookbook of his family's favorite recipes.
Rick doesn't want Morty wasting his time on this silly school project since they gotta go on adventures.
So, what does he do?
Rick fills up the rest of the book himself.
It's so interesting because like some of the cookbooks, they're like really well designed with like pictures of the food.
Just like the show, it's crazy and wacky and it feels like there's something fun to expect after every page turned.
I really love the layout of the book.
I think it's the perfect balance of text and imagery.
Lots of fun flavor text to read and very close in tone to the dark humor of the show.
There are no F-bombs or anything.
But there are some mature lines.
There's a lot of leading jokes in there that's very on brand.
I also really like how the recipe pages are littered with illustrations and even screenshots from the show.
And the screenshots are usually lifted from the same episode that the recipe is inspired by which is a neat addition.
The food photos are awesome as well and I really like the extra details in the staging of the food.
Some photos have lab equipment in the background to make them look like a part of Rick's lab and some photos have the characters interacting with the food.
The abundant illustrations and attention to detail really makes this one of the most thematic and most fun cookbooks to look at.
Not all recipes have photos but in this case I don't even mind because there's so much other good content to supplement it.
The recipes themselves are based off of food from the show or are inspired by references made in the show.
It's not just generic recipes with names thrown on them.
They really tried to draw things along and there are a lot of fun and crazy attempts to make some real dishes out of these crazy things.
Really impressed by how much this cookbook raises.
Now that we've had a look-see, it's time to get trying.
Let's try to break this space time continuum by making some interdimensional glove from the Rick and Morty cookbook.
Now we can't do Rick and Morty food without paying tribute to the iconic Pickle Rick.
After all, Pickle Rick won the show its first Emmy, launched a thousand memes, and inspired a bunch of merch, including this one.
So to make Pickle Rick's transformation brand, we need to mix the ingredients.
Stir it for a few minutes until it's light.
Close the midst of this hot dog porch on some battered lids.
In this recipe, cook the pork in a microwave for 15 seconds.
Don't let theiques cook thoroughly.
Keep stirring and heat the pot.
Mince the garlic.
As we can see, the garlic has been chopped.
Combine the sauce and sweet soy sauce.
The pork is ready to go.
Now is the time to try the garlic.
And it's really interesting because like you know he was like obviously like if he can make it like that means I can make it technically and uh and then he gives like a review and be like which one I want which one is good or not.
The store-bought ones are just much less of a hassle you know but if you're really looking to make homemade ones then this is a pretty solid recipe.
I like how it's green screen so you don't see the pickle.
But these chili dogs are the ones I've been eyeing up.
They definitely passed the eye test but they passed the taste test with flying colors.
This is pretty dang delicious.
So yeah this is honestly like one this is like one of my favorite channels to watch.
It's like oh my god I was watching the one piece one and then holy shit why is that curry blue?
What the fuck it's blue!
And then he made the bacon pancakes right here I watched that one.
And then there's the...
Uh okay there's one that I saw that I was like...
Wait look at this.
Look!
It's that fucking it's the one piece turkey!
It's the one piece turkey it looks so okay this looks actually looks so fucking good though like look at that.
It's the one piece turkey!
That looks so good!
The meat's sick!
The meat's still dried.
For my second bite I tried to get more of the drumstick meat which was way more moist and tasted a lot better.
Don't worry he like has his recipe for it.
What the fuck there's an egg inside!
I already forgot there was an egg inside.
How did he make that?
Don't worry just subscribe to Me So Hungry.
The best part is he tells the recipe in the video so you actually don't have to buy the book like you can just follow the recipe in his video which...
But if you really want to support the publisher, you should buy the book.
But if you really want to support the publisher, you could also buy the book.
But the best part is that he gives a step-by-step guide in the video itself.
So I don't have to worry about trying to figure out the recipe.
Oh my god, I'm so hungry now looking at this.
See, I think it's this one, right?
No, that's the meat on the bone here.
Meat on the bone.
Oh,
it wasn't turkey, it was a chicken!
No, it was a chicken.
Why did you start with food videos?
No, we started off with like...
We definitely did not start with food videos.
I'm sorry to all the vegans and vegetarians that are watching this.
It's not that much work, to be honest.
You just cut a chicken in half.
I saw a Reaper dance.
He started with Vocaloid.
But not the Vocaloid you're expecting.
Knead it all together and then mix in the milky breadcrumbs and knead it again.
Now to assemble the drumsticks, you're gonna need one hard-boiled egg per chicken drumstick.
Take the layers of meat and grate it around a hard-boiled egg.
Oh, you use it to shape it!
I see!
Then warm your hands and then take the meat mixture and cover the drumstick and egg so it looks like one honking meat drumstick.
Just like in the anime.
When everything is assembled, bake the drumsticks in the oven at 400 degrees Fahrenheit for 15-20 minutes.
If your drumstick still looks pale, I would raise the temp to 450 and then broil it for another 5-10 minutes to give it that nice brown color.
Which is what I did.
When done, you should have four nice plump meat on the roll.
If I wasn't so lazy, I'd do this.
God damn it!
If I wasn't a fucking streamer, I'd do this!
This is one of my favorite channels.
I'm really happy whenever they have new episodes.
I was always like, time to watch!
But I feel like he's so high effort.
Like his...
The stuff he does.
And his video production.
It's so high effort for like 150k subscribers.
You guys should check him out.
He's actually...
I feel like he's very underrated.
Also, here's one of my favorite videos.
I talked about it before, but I wanted to show you guys.
Because I couldn't show it on YouTube.
It was me, Barry.
I made them draw Lola Bunny with fewer sexual features so that you wouldn't be horny.
And reduce your blood flow to make you a millisecond slower.
Is it slow enough for me to...
Kill Iris?
Remember when you were making out with your first girlfriend?
It was me, Barry.
And you came right as she touched your leg?
I jerked you off at super speed so it would seem like you nutted at just a woman's touch.
Sorry, I had to...
It was me, Barry.
It was...
It was honestly...
One of my favorite...
Uh...
Reverse flash...
Reverse flash lines.
It's a classic!
It's such a classic!
Oh my god!
So my favorite like DC animator slash...
Okay, she does like Team Fortress 2 animations too.
Spineapples.
I don't know if you guys know Spineapples.
But like I fucking love her animations.
And like her like Team Fortress 2.
And like...
Her Team Fortress 2.
And DC animations are so good.
Like this one.
I love Spineapples.
What is this?
It's a meme, Batman.
I don't understand.
What do you not understand?
I don't get the joke.
Well, you see, people usually only play on one console.
But both these women are so attractive that you'd want to play with them both.
But they aren't consoles.
It's a classic!
The shirts they're wearing have the console logos on them.
Are you some kind of furry?
You're the one here wearing an animal suit.
It's true.
I think Batman's a furry.
Because why else would he dress up as a bat?
Checkmate.
But you guys should check out Spineapples.
He's like...
They're one of my favorite...
They're one of my favorite like animators.
They're like so OG.
Holy shit.
Some of their animations are like...
What is it?
Like four plus years ago.
Oh my god.
This rap.
The rap battle.
The spy rap.
Do you guys know the spy rap?
The one with Spy vs.
Tracer?
What's that?
Trust to the night.
No clue.
Is that a disguise?
With a classy suit and tie.
Who will look good at your funeral?
Bye!
It's time to murder this track.
You'll find a knife in its back.
Got equipment?
Watch me break it.
Saw me die?
I promptly faked it.
I'm a man of many faces.
Infiltrated plenty bases.
Stole your intel.
What a rush.
Even though there is much.
Oh, it's Sombra?
Oh, wait.
What was it?
Scout vs.
Tracer was the...
The OG rap.
I'm just pride on all your clothes.
And guess who won?
He's better.
Oh my god.
Okay, guys.
Guys.
OG.
OG raps.
Scout.
It's not cringe.
It was not cringe.
It's actually so good.
It's so good.
Back when, like, everyone fucking did rap battles.
Every...
Like, you know how, like, rap battles...
Like, rap battles of history, like, pioneered?
Okay, they didn't pioneer rap battles.
Like, it was there for a while.
But...
It's not cringe.
They were so good.
But, like, it made rap battles, like, with, like...
What's the word?
With, like, pop culture really popular.
So, then, people did, like, parodies.
With, uh...
They did parodies...
Oh my god.
It's still going?
They're so old now.
But they did, like, parodies with, like, games and, like, anime and stuff like that.
Fucking...
Bro, I love the Scout versus Tracer.
Scout versus Tracer was really good.
From JT.
Oh my god, Machinima.
I actually have the song in my fucking playlist!
I love it.
It happens everywhere.
Bop, bop, bop.
It's not cringe!
This was 6 years ago!
It was like it's history.
We were part of history!
You don't...
Okay, oh, yeah.
We don't miss Machinima.
...
Ha!
Even though he is talkin' to!
Hello, Georgey!
It's about time I battle you.
Ladies first.
Got an aptitude.
Check the time.
You're out of LambO ng fucking time!
Brody actually slaps.
It's just the animation is old.
It was six years ago.
It's not cringe.
Stop.
Oh yeah, I forgot about that.
Somebody said that they nerfed Tracer's ass, but like...
It never... It didn't really change that much to be fair, I feel like.
Okay, wait.
Sombra's spy was good too.
Guys, I swear!
You guys just don't understand!
Today's rap battle is brought to you by Roblox.
King weapon, free jerk.
It's nine!
Who's that dressed to the nines?
No clue.
They're so good!
They're rapping!
It's not a face.
It's not even super!
This was literally six years ago!
Wait, there's Mercy versus Medic?
I've never seen the Mercy versus Medic one.
What's the Mercy versus Medic?
They did so many.
God damn.
The animation is so dated.
Where's Medic?
I don't care about Mercy.
Whoa!
Okay, not gonna lie.
The voice acting for this is pretty good.
It looks like a nerve.
Yes, I think it's work.
Feeling is not as rewarding as a hurting.
Okay, this was pretty bad.
I'll admit.
This one was pretty bad.
Okay.
I'll give you guys that, that one was pretty bad.
Okay, but did you guys know like...
The TF2 like cast... cast actually did like a song cover together?
I saved it because I was like...
Whoa, what?
That's the Team Fortress 2 voice actors.
Okay, where is it?
I saved the video too.
It's called the Sandwich Blues.
They actually did like...
Yeah, they did.
This was like a month ago.
Last month.
Woke up this morning.
The package was gone.
Didn't leave no note.
Nothing to go on.
Looked under the covers.
Under the sheet.
Now Heavy's broken hearted.
He's got nothing to eat.
We got the Sandwich Blues.
Way down in our souls.
Yeah, they're doing like song covers now, which I thought was funny.
This can't be happening.
Oh God, they're so old.
Yeah, I think they're like in their 50s or 60s now.
Or they have to be in 60s.
Gonna have a plan.
Where we gonna look.
In so many places.
We could write a book.
I've been to California.
Boys actors are so talented.
I've been to Peru.
I can only do like creepy voices.
What are we going to do?
We got the Sandwich Blues.
Way down in our souls.
Things are taking a toll.
This can't be happening.
Heavy is out of control.
Please stop it, Heavy.
We got a mysterious woman.
She's even got a past.
Oh yeah, this boy.
The...
What was it?
What's her name?
The announcer?
The announcer and Sniper are like married.
Ira.
She's met us in a bar.
But we ain't got no sandwich.
We only got a call.
We got the Sandwich Blues.
Way down in our souls.
Don't need to take a poll.
If we don't find it soon, Heavy going to eat a throne.
Yeah, they're doing like...
They're doing like music covers now together, which I thought was really cute.
Spies cogitated.
Maybe it's a curse.
Edmund's intimidating.
She's nobody's nurse.
If we don't find the sandwich, Heavy's gonna need a hearse.
We got the Sandwich Blues.
Way down in our souls.
It's still the Sandwich Blues.
Put it on a scroll.
All right, guys.
Now we're going to see something really cursed.
I need to show you guys this video.
Look at this hippie crap.
I'm sure no one will be creeped out by this.
No.
This popped up.
I like...
Look, it's this boss.
It's the boss.
It's the boss and dog.
Look into it.
Look.
For those who don't know, they're going to create something very special.
So I bought a robotic dog.
This video is brought to you by Squarespace.
No, not this video.
So what...
So they're going to make something beautiful today with Furby.
So how are we actually going to turn our robot into a Furby?
Well, we know someone who has a lot of experience 3D printing Furby projects.
I never...
Like these masks.
I want that mask.
Holy shit.
That's terrifying.
That's fucking terrifying.
By the way, I've never watched a full video.
Only watched like the final product.
So I actually don't know what it is.
I don't know how they made this.
Our first step was to 3D scan the robot and send it to him so he could accurately model the Furby parts for it.
I'm collecting so many points of data.
I'm going to angle down and kind of get some of the notes.
Show me your nooks and crannies.
Show me your crannies!
Evan zooming in on his butt.
Well, good posing.
So we just got an update from Austin.
He has a few different mock-ups of different forms the Furby could take.
Wait, different forms?
There's more than one?
When we were originally talking about this idea, Evan was showing like, see if we can try to put the Furby's face like directly over the front of it.
Oh god, that's more terrifying than what it was.
Not in what it came to be.
The best ones that I could think of and included like some of the pros and cons that I think we've got.
Yes, I'm ready.
So the first option.
Oh no.
I'm just gonna say this up front.
It's possible that these mock-ups might be too good.
I know, that's really good.
Such glorious heights.
Here we go, we'll start with the pros.
He's huggable.
I thought about like baby doll arms sort of thing.
I've got mixed feelings.
Yeah.
There's plenty of room for the electronics cons.
It might just look like it's a Furby sitting on a dog's head.
Attachment points is another thing that we might need to figure out.
Yeah, we want to make sure it's not top heavy and toppling.
Wait, what's the spider?
Oh no!
I'm so uncomfortable!
No Furby on your back!
No Furby!
Once again, it could look like a Furby riding back to the dog.
We could have people commenting how it doesn't actually have six legs.
Well, spiders have eight legs, so we'd have a lot of legs to have.
So this is the last one.
I call this one Mr. No Neck.
What is that?
Oh god!
It looks like a primate Furby.
It uses less material.
Yeah, very human-like.
It's so cool!
That looks so cool though!
Look!
Think of the Twitch Prime!
Thank you!
But the original thing that brought up this whole issue was the front sensors.
Yeah.
It might be okay, but we could just avoid the whole worry by going with the centaur, you know?
Even though Mr. No Neck looks amazing and that was actually one of my original visions, I'm most curious about the centaur.
What about you?
I am also, I think, leaning towards centaur.
I feel like it gives us a little bit more wiggle room in terms of electronics.
And honestly, I thought it would be much more cursed feeling to me, but he almost feels like a llama.
Oh yeah!
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah!
He looks so huggable!
To be fair, if you compare this with the other two that we saw, like this looks so cute now.
This looks actually cute compared to the other ones that we saw.
It actually makes it look good.
I mean, compared to the fucking spider and the No Neck?
Come on!
The belly doesn't have any moving parts though.
So we thought we'd add a pop of color with pink inspired by the original grey and pink furby we bought.
I had a furby.
I had the furby and those little dog ones.
Little dog pets.
And then the...
How is it?
The cat ones as well.
No Neck was not cute.
No- I don't know what you guys are thinking.
It looks like a fucking monkey with a furby attached to his head.
We can just shave it, right?
It doesn't make it better.
Oh, for real friends!
Yes!
That's a pretty good match.
Yeah, it's a good match for the grey.
You combine that with the pink, I feel like it's very furby-esque.
That's very furby-esque.
We did it, baby.
He's gonna be so hairy.
I like how they're giving us a tutorial on making our very own furby.
It's so furbycore, yeah.
You cover that with tape.
And then you sharpie over the tape, cut out your pattern, and then make that in fabric.
Yeah, let's see how this works.
Any like- I need you guys to know, these cost like, what is it?
They cost like more than 30 grand, right?
The Boston Robots on its own?
Yeah.
Any like super rich dragoons wanna make a dragoon version of- We'll only have to do a dragoon version.
Oh, like 10k.
Oh, it's less now.
It used to be like crazy expensive when they first launched.
Oh, it's 1,600 now?
Wait, that's a steal!
Any like engineer dragoons?
Any engineer dragoons that can make this?
Oh yeah, cause it's like mass produced now.
When it first came out, it was like crazy fucking expensive.
The lady didn't cut it, she ripped it.
Which maybe is best practice for this type of fabric, but she had to use so much effort.
She was like, hold on, I need to chug this real quick.
I could buy one, but I'm not an engineer.
I can't make my own dragoon version of this.
And then she moved on to the other one, and I was like, can I help?
Like, I don't know what to- I didn't know what to do to like be helpful, but she was just destroying the thing.
Oh, this is now from Boston Dynamics?
It's a bootleg?
Can I copy your homework?
Let me change it up a little bit.
Okay, let's take a little dress, a little tiktok.
Oh yeah.
Oh, this cut's fine.
I don't know why she didn't cut it.
They just need some heavy frickin' duty scissors.
They have heavy frickin' duty scissors.
It's Joanne's.
I don't know what was going on.
Either way, I was rooting for her the whole time.
Can I see that cross section?
So I'm gonna skip the fur part.
Oh my god.
What?
Look at it!
That's kind of glorious.
Do you want to do the rest of the leg and see what it looks like?
Oh, they're like plastic wrapping it so the fur doesn't come off.
Oh, they're getting like the pattern.
I see.
There you go, there you go.
Can you imagine it?
We're skipping the fur part of the Furby.
Oh my god.
We did such a good job!
It actually looks so good.
Oh my god.
You guys can see the Boston 9-9ers when they're crazy expensive.
I'm like having a little bit showing at the elbow and stuff.
It doesn't bother me at all.
Like, here it is.
You zoom out, you don't even notice that.
Yeah.
Hey, thank you for the Thank you for the tear once up.
Thank you, thank you.
See, it doesn't look that fucked up.
He's getting a Furby.
When we started this project, I really had no clue how we were gonna make it happen.
It doesn't look that bad, guys!
I'll tell you guys, the end result looks so cute.
We're doing it.
We don't have any new dance patterns or anything like that, but we are winging it, and it's working.
Okay.
Can you walk without the fur getting caught in the joints?
I was not smart enough to do this.
Maybe we check, maybe we check after the walk.
Imagine my stream is just making like Furby abominations.
Oh my god, look at him dance!
Oh yeah, he's moving.
Oh, he's tap dancing.
Oh, he's moving and grooving.
That's so cute!
This is my new pet.
Yeah!
Hey, little guy.
I remember when the Boston Dynamics released the first video, the dog, and all they did was just push it around and hit it.
People were like, No!
Can we know a little bit of what we're doing?
But we haven't seen what it looks like.
Stop!
Is that a note?
Oh my god!
Awesome!
The exhilarating Furbot instruction manual!
Oh my gosh!
Look at this!
This is so fantastic!
First thing I see is this adorable thing.
Yeah, you guys are gonna see an even more adorable thing later.
I feel like it's Christmas.
I know.
Look at the gaming person!
That's a square face!
No!
I don't get paid!
Can I kiss?
Square face doesn't sponsor this!
Guys, no!
Don't type that URL!
Instead, type the gamer subs way!
Don't type this URL!
Step 1.
Insert both support arms into the main support base and tighten both...
We don't get paid!
Step 2.
Slide battery power bank into dedicated slot on backup quadruped.
Step 3.
Wrap, buckle, and tighten down both support straps around the quadruped robot.
Guys, I'll pay somebody to follow these instructions.
Okay, play Furby body on main screen.
And make a dragoon version of this.
I will pay you.
I will pay a dragoon to make a dragoon version of this.
Yeah, it's just like the bones.
I can see the mouth through there.
Where's your Squarespace sponsorship?
I don't know Squarespace!
Where is my Squarespace sponsorship?
That's asleep right now.
Oh, this is...
Oh my god!
And then have it run around conventions.
And just terrorize people.
Oh god!
I don't like...
I think he looks worse with the eyes closed.
Oh, I hate that.
I don't like that.
I think it's like really bad because he doesn't even have fur.
It's like a skinned Furby.
God save us all!
That's awful!
Maverick, thank you for the toy fun!
Get that sus!
Thank you!
He's like awakening as he's being operated on.
Like his anesthesia is lifting.
Oh my god!
Let's open the box.
Let's open this last box.
I hate this abomination.
That's so sweet.
Oh my god!
Is that...
Oh, it's so cute!
They made pens dispenser as a gift.
Hehehe.
Stop looking at me.
Mmm.
Just like chalk.
Okay.
Back to it.
Let's make it say something.
Ready?
Yeah.
D 'oh.
Oh.
Subscribe, subscribe to Evan.
Okay, look.
For all the...
I'm saying... all I'm saying Dragoons.
I'll pay someone to make a Dragoon equivalent version of this.
And then I want it to run around different conventions and be like, subscribe to Doki Berry.
Reven time.
Er, er, er.
I will pay a smart engineering dragoon to do this.
I will do it.
I think the investment goes a long way.
Curse mode?
What's curse mode?
I'm so tempted to press it.
I know, me too.
I want to press it, but I feel like we need to finish him first.
And then see what can be more cursed than he already is.
Oh!
The Dark Souls!
The curse of Furby!
Oh my god!
Yes!
This is everything that I hoped for!
Icy, thank you for the Twitch Prime!
Thank you!
The Power Stats.
Wait, is that even curse mode?
Is it curse mode yet?
I'm ready.
Oh yeah, they're going to put fur on it now?
Help!
Oh my god.
They're like mummifying you.
They're doing it.
It's almost like they're mummifying the Furby.
I 3D printed some ears.
Can you see me?
I can see you.
It's evolving in real time.
It's getting so dusty.
I'm literally immune.
I seriously think I'm more used to cat hair being on me.
Like, this is normal.
I don't know.
It's like more fur than robotics if you think about it.
Oh god, his neck is so long.
Guys, don't look yet.
There's another child I really like to watch that does like repurposing Halloween decorations.
Hi Hope y'all got a lot of fun.
Yeah Oh my god, look at him all strut.
Oh my God, shaking is a backboard.
Not to pat ourselves on the back, but like we did a really good job.
Oh, my God.
He's outside.
I can see totally.
He is very cursed.
But he can still move around.
But he's got that Furby vibe.
There you go!
Bro, he's better than a real dog!
Because he can actually talk!
He'll be like, Doki, what happened to Doki Amber Doge?
And then... Oh!
He's got eggs!
They're eggs!
Let our new friends introduce themselves.
Hello, Evan.
Coco.
Thank you for helping my past owner bring me to life.
With damage so much more than mine, I am no longer well for
now.
Coco seems like a nice guy.
So I think he's ready to be introduced to the world.
What do you think?
He seems safe.
Yeah!
Safe!
Coco seems like a nice guy!
Oh my god!
Seeing him move like that is so scary!
Oh my god, he's like shaking his hips!
Oh, we have the evil mode!
We never got to see evil mode!
I never got to see evil mode!
Oh, the button!
Evan's pushing the button!
What's evil mode?
What does it look like?
Oh, I don't like... Oh...
Oh, I don't like evil... Oh!
I don't... I don't like evil mode.
Imagine just having this running around during Halloween.
Oh no.
It like looks towards me.
Killer feet!
Thank you for the tier one sub!
Thank you!
No!
Shall we take him out?
Let's take him out!
I'm sure no one will be creeped out by this.
Alright, so I watched the ending.
I skipped all the... I skipped like how to make it.
But I watched the ending of this.
Yeah, like just taking it out for a walk.
I didn't even know about the curse mode.
I love how they gave Coco a dog tag and a collar.
And it's named Coco!
The dog tag is named Coco!
Oh no!
Oh god, it's so...
The poor dog!
And then look at my eyes.
That is so rad.
That is so rad!
That was awesome!
That was so cool!
He's like...
He's a propaganda dog.
Yeah.
So rad.
He likes it.
I think so.
It's like a real dog.
This guy has infected with internet.
Be used later for protection and security when they put a gun attached to it.
The new protection.
Oh my god, look!
He's picking up the bus!
It's like a real dog!
Coco!
Is it a beautiful family?
Thanks again to Austin.
Don't forget to check out post video.
Oh Beautiful!
I'll...
All I'm saying guys.
All I'm saying is I'll 100 percent invest in this.
If any very smart engineer goons out there make a Dragoon equivalent of this.
This is the TikTok video I saw.
I feel like this was worse.
This is a lot worse.
Oh, look at this!
It taught your cat to play piano!
Look at this!
Oh my god.
I bet you the Furby dog can learn piano faster than this cat.
It's so cute!
Look!
He's learning!
His brain is expanding!
He's playing on his own!
That's so cute!
Anyway, I felt like you guys needed that to...
We needed the cleanser for that.
Also, I was watching people make school lunches.
Okay, I was watching somebody watch the school lunch shit.
But I've also watched actual parents making school lunches.
And I'm just like, holy shit!
The amount of effort and time.
Look at this!
We're gonna watch somebody reacting to this.
I'll get the actual channel.
So we don't react to the person reacting.
But I was like, looking at her making school lunches.
And I'm like, Jesus!
Oh my god!
She does so much too!
Reacception!
Like, look at this!
Oh my god.
Whoops.
I forgot to put it in a playlist.
Like, she has like...
There's like different stuff like bath times.
And like, she does like DIYs for like her dogs.
And water.
And stuff like that.
And I'm like, oh my god!
That's like so much effort.
My mom just buys stuff.
Okay, wait.
Let me show you guys.
Alright.
Where's my playlist?
Where's my liked videos?
There it is.
Alright, here.
I was like...
The commitment to this.
Ugh.
She has a whole drawer for like her kids.
Like...
This is just dedicated to making food for her children.
What a mom!
Like, she has like...
Like, there's like...
There's a lot of these channels of like moms making school lunches.
Or like just like lunch and dinner for their children.
And like...
One of the moms like showed their fucking collection of cookie cutters.
It was actually crazy.
They had like...
Oh, I think like a hundred cookie cutters for different themes.
Like...
The budget for this?
Not gonna lie.
Okay, this is fucked up for me to say.
Uh...
This is...
This is so fucked up for me to say.
But like...
I feel like...
She could buy...
Healthier foods...
For their child.
Um...
Like that's tastier.
For like...
One third of the price...
Of all this stuff.
She has.
Yes!
Like...
It's like...
Look...
Cause you need two cookie cutters?
And then...
Look at all this...
Oh my god.
That's a lot of seasoning.
Like she has like a snack drawer too.
And then like a container for Cheez-Its?
Anyway, she does like...
But it's crazy.
She's like so dedicated to her child.
Because...
Because she made like...
Uh...
Her own bakery.
For her child.
I'm like...
Oh my god.
She's so creative.
That shit is so bougie.
She doesn't know how to sew.
But look at what she made.
Look at all that.
This is amazing.
Oh, she does that.
Listen up!
I was so excited.
Can you close that?
OK, she's collecting this little big plate?
I am a mess.
Oh my god.
What was that?
what was that?
That little Tori Grimes.
Ley.
If you know what Leeroy's talking about...
Have you heard of this story?
Oh my god!
I want to be this fucking parent's child!
Look at this!
This screams of mommy issues!
It's not fair!
And then there's...
For my daughter's lunch today, we are doing a deconstructed...
What the fuck!
Look at all these cookie cutters!
That's what I'm saying!
I actually subscribed to this other mom channel that makes lunches for their kids.
And it's more than this.
She has so many cookie cutters.
It's actually crazy.
This lunch box is perfect for this meal because it contains a thermos compartment that will keep the noodles warm.
First up are turkey dogs, broccoli, and a pizza.
And the cutest ball of soy sauce.
This child is definitely an only child!
Oh no, for real.
No, she is definitely...
And of course, our spoon and fork.
I know some of y'all love to drag my lunch box ideas...
There's a mini... do you see that mini Heinz?
Is that mini Heinz?
What is that?
Like a soy...
It's so tiny!
They come in that size?
...to drag my lunch box ideas.
So for clarification, this is a loose interpretation of a ramen bowl.
Not to be taken literally.
My four-year-old is my harshest critic, so if she loves it, that's all.
Oh my god, she...
No, no, you are not using her Amazon link.
Anyway, so there's like... these are the things I watch, by the way.
I don't like critique it as harsh as this.
It's just like, I'm just watching it and I was like, oh my god.
Here I am ordering Uber Eats while she makes a fucking like Mona Lisa lunch for her child.
No pre-advertising.
Alright, where's this other one I want to show you guys?
Oh, look at this!
Okay, okay, look at it.
Where is it?
There was like... did you guys know?
Okay, at one point, my algorithm was filled with like Lego builders.
And like, there was like this... apparently there's like custom Lego blocks.
Where is it?
I was... I got recommended some like custom Legos.
And I was like, what the fuck?
Oh wait, here you go.
In this box is $211 worth of custom cursed Lego parts which are the weirdest in the world.
Let's find out what's inside.
The first item is a custom Walter White from Breaking Bad.
Walter comes with, of course, some nice blue candy.
I looked at the website and like...
In this bag, we have an Amazon Prime box and a custom military helmet.
I also got this very strange long head.
I love the long head ones.
I actually sort of like the long heads.
I don't know what these guys are, but they look funny enough.
Um, here we have this guy with an extremely tiny face.
Look at his tiny face!
I also got this weird double-faced head.
And also this drunken long clown face.
I also bought this calculator with a hidden message when you flip it upside down.
Too bad I can't read.
Here's this cracked phone.
A US passport.
A bounce trap.
I also got this oddly chilled sock monkey.
A snack people were eating for some reason.
Here's a magic eight ball.
Here we have an innocent videotape.
Lastly, a pouch of blood.
It's so cool.
Wait, what the fuck?
What is that?
What is this video that I liked?
Was this an accident?
I'm scared.
I don't actually remember this video that I liked.
But also did you guys know these like channels?
Wait, keep going.
What is this?
Guys.
There's like this channel.
Whos that keep going?
AHHHHHH!
Anyway, anyway so there's like this channel.
By the way.
There's like this channel.
I didn't watch the ending of that.
I just need you guys to know I just saw the star scream and I thought that was cool.
I didn't watch the ending.
I didn't...
I...
Okay.
So like there are like two videos showing up like this full screen.
There's like these random Russian channels.
I don't know if it's like I can't tell if it's deepfake or not But like I think it's deepfake because people are like debating debating it in comments and Oh, sorry Megatron People were debating about it in in like comments whether or not these are like deepfakes or or actual or like actual uh Like what's it?
What's it called?
Doppelgangers?
But like there's like three of them like four of them.
There's one of like Leo.
There's There's one with the Wednesday girl actor The other one was what's her name the Barbie actress and then the Charlie and the chocolate factory factory actor But it's actually so crazy.
They're all they all have the same name too And it's like some Russian some like Russian channel Let me check.
I'll show you guys.
It's actually crazy.
I was like what the fuck Let's see, I'm pretty sure it's deepfake.
I think it's deepfake, but like they have like they have several It's actually crazy.
They have like so many different channels Yeah, it says fake but like people don't know if it's like actors like that just looked like them or or like actually If they're actually just like deepfakes Cuz like look at this Okay, not like this I keep forgetting to like the videos cuz I did the format like that
This has to be deepfake, right?
Right, that's deepfake, right?
That has to be deepfake, right?
I can't tell it's so good
I can't tell it's so good It's actually great technology is like crazy now and it's so hard to tell these days if it's deepfake or not What is this?
Now I'm scared.
I love this.
I love this youtuber.
I love this guy this guy that makes like crazy shit for his figures Oh my god, you guys should check him out Yoshi channel This guy's insane.
Look at him go
Look at that
It's actually insane he's so talented I was like watching a lot of his videos of him like making like props for his figures
Like what the fuck look he made he made that with his hands what the hell What the hell?
I thought that was his voltron Holy shit It's like survival gang crap dig Like he made all of this!
It's actually insane That he's able to make that Okay wait, let me show you his channel.
It's actually I like love his work.
I recently discovered stuff But like there's like a slower version of it But he does like um, figure mods and stuff too so Oh this one, this one's good.
I mean, I like it.
Let me like some of the stuff he made.
There's like, he does like lots of like minor, like not minor, but huge mods on figures.
Like oh my god, I saw the dragon one and I was like holy fuck.
The dragon one was, was so talented.
Like videos.
Watch this.
Look at that.
Oh my god, he carved all that out of a fucking styrofoam.
Like he carved scales.
He actually carved scales out of a fucking styrofoam.
Yeah, he's making the dragon.
What the fuck the head?
Get this guy a 3D print.
Like, this is styrofoam.
This is better than 3D printer.
Bro, this is handmade.
He don't need, yeah he is the printer.
Guys, this man is the fucking 3D printer.
This goes so hard.
Like I recently discovered his channel.
Like he...
Not only can he make, not only can he make like whole uh like props for his figures, but he can make a fucking figure himself.
He doesn't even need to buy figures anymore.
He can literally make them.
What's the channel name?
It's a Yoshi channel.
Got a 3D printer.
If any kid destroys this, he can make it again.
but he's gonna fall so deep now lol Yeah H Mort.
thank you you do good job I love your editing.
I love the editing too.
I feel like those like uh the the creative side of YouTubers can edit so well.
Thank you very much.
Aww, so sweet!
Okay, not the deep fake again.
Alright, I'm showing you guys normal videos now.
Chat.
I'm showing you guys normal videos now.
Okay, I'm trying to find...
Alright, let's see.
Oh, this one I saw was pretty funny.
I wish gender reveals were as fun as this.
Do you want a boy?
How is this normal?
This should be the norm for gender reveals.
Dude, I...
I'm tired.
Oh my god, he did like the Undertaker.
Don't be pleased to find normal.
This should be normal!
I'm tired of the force fires that be started because of gender reveals.
I'm so tired.
And the cakes too!
Cakes aren't original!
Much less property damage.
Exactly!
It's a boy!
Also, there is...
Which one was it?
Let's see.
What are things...
What was I going to show you guys?
Uh...
There's like videos I've liked as well.
Let me look through my archives.
Oh my god!
I love watching these!
So like, these are like tours around like cool places in Japan.
And there's one where it's like literally a town dedicated to dinosaurs.
So like, I was watching this and it's like a whole train that's just dinos.
Hahaha!
It's like a dinosaur train!
I thought it was so cool!
I was like, this is so cute!
I wanna be on this train!
Name, please?
It's called Itsuka Japan.
Japan's largest dinosaur museum.
It's so... it's so...
interesting.
It's like...
It's like those like trains that are themed.
So like there's like Pokemon themed trains.
And like...
and like others.
But this one's Dino themed.
Look!
Oh my god!
There's a T-Rex head!
I was watching this video like a couple of weeks ago.
It's so cool!
So you ride this train to go to the museum.
It's so cute!
There's like so many interesting ones.
And there's like...
Oh, this one.
This one's scary.
I wanna be on this train!
Clever girl!
He watched the pretty random videos!
I just... I don't know!
I just...
I'm very cultured, I guess.
I watch a lot of fucking random videos.
I grew up on the internet.
Finally a normal video.
My algorithm is like crazy.
I just watch like different stuff.
I'm not... I don't like just watch funny videos.
I watch like craft videos and stuff.
An insight into Doki's mind!
Look at that!
It's so cute!
Oh, what's the next to this?
And then there's like a museum.
It's just a museum dedicated to it and stuff.
So there's like dino themed food and everything.
And...
What's this?
Oh my god!
Merch!
Buy my merch!
Anyway, so...
I thought this channel was really interesting.
I enjoy it.
Because they tour around Japan.
Showing like interesting themed places and stuff.
And then... Oh my god!
Okay, this is one of my favorite craft videos.
I don't know if you know this.
They make like clay.
Wuzu clay.
I really enjoy their stuff.
It's so cute.
And very peaceful.
They mostly do like Minecraft because of the algorithm.
Uh...
But I found the way they do like the clay art to be like really creative.
Like I like the little template they use to help make the clay art.
Minecraft IRL.
Yeah!
That's what he does!
So interesting.
And they put this piece together.
Put it together!
It's so peaceful.
But you can see that it slowly becomes...
Like look at that!
Oh my god, it's all coming together.
It's very satisfying.
What a submarine!
It's a fucking Minecraft shipwreck.
And they're making the...
What are they making?
Are they making a box?
The bottom base of it, I think?
Yeah, so they're making the sand and the...
The sand biome.
So nice.
Very relaxing.
I can do that.
Yeah?
Where's your 2 million subscribers channel?
Where is it?
Oh my god, it fits perfectly!
Ba la la la la.
I like how there's like Christmas background music in the background.
Where's yours?
Exactly.
That is why I'm not talented enough, and I said I yoink people's content for react.
That's why That's why I don't have 2 million subscribers.
Let's go react at these.
Hey, what's that?
Oh, that's not the seaweed, right?
I haven't watched this video yet.
I watched his other clay videos.
Oh my god, imagine like, putting...
Those could be like, surgeon fingers too.
I feel like instead of becoming a surgeon...
It's either you be a surgeon with those...
With those like, steady hands, or like...
Or a crafter.
Yeah, the tiny details.
And then the coral!
Oh my god, they're all broken!
This could, but this is...
Yeah,
that's so fucking tiny!
Oh, I love Tiny Kitchen.
I watch their stuff too.
I love Tiny Kitchen.
Grab it!
Thank you for the tier 1 stuff!
Thank you, thank you!
And the tiny sea pickles.
And then the coral and the seaweed.
And then the tiny boat!
God,
with a chest!
That's so cute!
It's so tiny!
Oh my god, there's Jack Black!
Hahaha!
Tony, please!
It's true!
Jack Black's gonna be Steve in Minecraft!
You guys didn't know that?
It's so cute.
Finally, Jack Black is real.
Oh, the tiny axolotl!
Yeah, I'm serious!
He's gonna be Steve in Minecraft!
They just finished filming!
Oh my god, the axolotl is so cute!
Oh!
I love his stuff.
And then you're gonna add resin.
I love the crafting channels.
They're so relaxing to watch.
I thought she was joking.
Holy shit, it's so tiny!
Next to the Lego?
I didn't realize how tiny it was!
And then you're gonna put resin on it.
Wait, they're making their own diorama!
My god!
They didn't even buy a diorama, they made their own diorama!
Oh god, pushing that down would make me so scared!
Yeah, they made their little wood stand!
I'd be so scared pushing that down.
And so they have to mix the resin.
The thing about resin is that it has to be like 50-50 exactly.
Because of chemistry.
If it's not 50-50 exactly...
You fuck up the resin.
It's so good!
And the air bubbles make sense because it's water.
Holy shit!
Are they gonna take off the...
Are they gonna take off the glass part or are they gonna keep that in?
Oh, I guess they'll keep that in.
It's so sick!
I know!
He's so talented!
I love his stuff!
Yeah, you fuck up the resin and it's done for.
You have to remake the whole thing.
I know it's so good!
I love his shit!
I love his works.
It's actually so good.
Everything is like super precise and everything.
Alright, now that we're talking about crafting channel...
Let me show you guys another...
Another craft person that I like to watch.
Let me see if I can find it.
Let's see.
Where is it?
I love watching craft channels.
It's like my life.
It's wuzu clay.
Oh, there.
I love like these like...
Pokemon cards dioramas too.
I think these are...
Really unique.
Like the 3D card dioramas.
That stuff is... That's like... That's so pretty.
Those are really cool.
Yeah.
And because they need like multiple too.
They need more than one card to make this.
So they have to like...
Like they want to use like authentic Pokemon cards.
So like they have to make...
Buy like multiple copies of it.
I love Doll Life.
Doll Life was one of my favorite doll creators.
And also speaking of dolls.
Because I saw a lot of people like...
The Doki Bird doll dropped from Moonlight Jewel as well.
I love watching doll videos.
But like the Doki Bird doll video dropped as well.
I haven't watched it yet.
Like oh...
Look.
Holy shit.
It's so pretty.
I want...
I want like a Doki Bird card diorama.
One day in the future.
That's so pretty.
Like oh my god.
It's so good.
Alright before we do.
We should like watch something fucked up.
Before we watch something normal.
Man I wish I could show like...
Some of the animation channels I watch.
But the humor in it might...
Is like really fucked up.
Because I told you guys like...
So my favorite animation channel is like...
There's Cass.
There's Flash Gitz.
And there's Meat Canyon.
But like I feel like...
What if I show you guys...
The humor's not for everybody.
But like...
Those are...
That's my humor.
That's technically my humor.
Let's see.
Oh...
I saw like this song for learning Japanese.
And I thought it was like...
Really cute.
Look.
This is by...
Let's learn Japanese today.
For those who need to learn Japanese,
this is not actually helpful!
Okay, the reason why is that I saw this version of it, which was really nice.
This is how Doki learns Japanese.
That's...
That's cute that you think that I'm ever gonna learn Japanese.
My brain...
My brain cannot fit another language.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Not with that attitude.
We've tried.
We've tried so many times.
Guys...
That's cute that you guys think I'm ever gonna learn.
That's so true.
Let's see.
What else?
What else do I want to show you guys?
Let's look at the...
Oh my god!
Okay, have you guys seen those rug videos?
I've been watching...
I've been watching the people make rug...
Okay, a lot of the videos I watch is actually just like relaxing videos too.
Like some of my favorite channels.
But I love watching people make rugs.
I don't know why.
I just think it's like super soothing.
It's so interesting too.
The rug making videos.
No, not the cleaning ones.
I just watch people make rugs.
That's it.
I literally watch people make rugs.
Nice too.
The ASMR of it.
It sounds so relaxing.
It's so talented too.
Because you have to be like super precise with everything.
Oh, look at that.
And then trimming it all.
And then making it so that like things are...
Making it so that these are more bumpy than the others.
Oh, I've seen the art restoration videos.
Yeah, I have.
Look at that.
Oh my god.
I want this rug.
Can someone make a Doki Bird rug?
Alright, let's watch the doll video.
I haven't watched it yet.
I saved it though.
Here it is.
Hey ho.
So if you guys have been watching me for a while you probably know that I have made some Vtuber dolls in the past.
That's me.
I'm a Vtuber.
I love doll making videos.
I thought how about I make another Vtuber doll before I make my own doll.
I'm taking a tiny break from posting because planning my wedding is a lot.
Amazingly enough, the decision who to make was made pretty easy when I saw that the amazing Doki Bird hosted a cherry stream and searched for artists to participate in that.
The artworks and items that the artists offered would then be auctioned off and the proceeds would go to cherry.
So I applied, got accepted, and offered a slot of a custom Doki Bird doll that will go with your new home as well.
Which is what we are going to do today.
As always, Blue Pixie did an amazing job by already sculpting a beautiful face and some of her accessories.
So how about we get my 3D printer and some resin prepped and start this project by printing the doll.
Holy shit, what the fuck is that?
What is that machine?
Is that a 3D printer?
Wait, what?
Are 3D printers like that now?
Oh my god, that has to be a fucking...
Oh, it's a resin printer?
They can 3D print resin now?
Wait, that's insane.
That has to be crazy expensive.
Oh my god, those are my legs.
Whoa.
Naked.
I really love the little smug smile on her face and I'm happy that the printing and assembling went so well.
And now that the preparations are done, we can now actually start working on the doll.
Does that have the project?
How about we make her wake?
Holy shit, wait, I'm thick.
I have those thighs.
Wait.
One recent trend that I picked up was people telling their own stories through short form content.
I think the cat is coming.
I wanted to learn more about this subject and then found this class from Haleaza Navarra.
Okay, sorry, I'm gonna skip your ad.
It's Skillshare.
But like, she reminded me of this other channel that I really like to watch.
I think it's nerdy.
What was it?
It's also a crafting channel too.
Her personality reminds me of that channel where it's...
I'm trying to remember.
They make really cool gaming stuff as well.
They once made a custom PC that was inspired by Cyberpunk.
I'm trying to remember the name.
I should watch some of their stuff.
NerdForge!
Yes!
I love NerdForge!
NerdForge is one of my favorite channels.
It's so cool.
An essential item that I found recently for making wigs is this matte styling wax.
Because with this you can really mold the hair into shape.
It's amazing.
To make Ducky's bangs a little more spiky, I thin out the hair by vertically cutting into them and then use the styling wax and heat to mold them in shape.
The curling wand is an excellent tool for flattening down the hair as well.
When I was satisfied with the look, I then proceed and glue, cut, and style her heme bangs.
The front of her hairstyle was actually not that easy to mimic which is why I decided to start the wig with it this time.
The heme bangs are kind of layered and it was a bit tricky to make that work.
My hair that complicated?
I feel like the skin suit has to be like easier.
I love my skin suit.
The skin suit was easier.
And then finally start on the back of the head.
For the pigtail look I will go around here in the direction of the pigtails on the back of her head.
Afterwards it looks a bit messy and believe me it was.
But I basically just had to pull all the glued hair into a pigtail.
And then for the final layers I prepped a bunch of folded around glued wefts which I now will be using to create all the parting lines on the wig.
This was a lot of work and I've been working on the wig for the whole day already and it was evening and I was pretty tired so I did that off camera.
Oh my god look at all that hair.
There's so many hairs too.
Ava thank you for the rain!
Thank you thank you!
Yeah!
Hello everybody!
It's me Ducky DuckyBraid.
I do the stream on the YouTube but today I'm on Twitch because I'm a React Andy today.
Oh my gosh the ribbon is so cute!
On which I now can finally attach the ribbons with some hot glue.
I actually did try to make Ducky's head out of fabric but I failed miserably.
So Blue came to the rescue here and sculpted Ducky's head so I could then CD print it in resin.
Wait the hat's so cute!
That's so pretty!
And then I just have to simply paint it according to Ducky's style of artwork.
Hats are very hard to make in general.
I love how broad it looks and will now also glue it to the wig so that it won't fall off and potentially break in worst case since resin is a little bit more brittle than filament and tends to break more easily.
The finished wig looks so cute already and I'm really proud of the little bows.
I'm not a fan of making pig tail wigs but I love how they look in the end.
Let's paint Ducky's face next.
Lupixi did such a nice job sculpting it that you can already tell by the sculpt itself that it is really Ducky Bird.
As always I'm giving the face some sheen with pearly shimmers.
You can really go a bit overboard with them as sealing them with Mr. Super Clear later on will make them disappear a little again.
I also add a little bit of blushing to different areas of the face.
I know anime faces tend to look more flat so adding a little bit more blushing... I think that's like the hardest part with uh...
the hardest part with like painting figures is to make it not like one dimensional type deal and adding shading.
I think that's like the hardest part.
I've seen so many like custom figures and stuff that like um...
that like forget to do like the important parts of shading cause it's so hard to make it look bright as well.
I then can finally go in with black acrylic paint and carefully line the lashes with it.
Of course I also have to line Ducky's cute little smug smile using some gouache paint.
Mistakes can be carefully scratched away with an exacto knife.
So cute!
To give the eyebrows a little bit more of a blonde look I decided to use a little bit of pastel yellow on the middle of them and I really like the look.
For the finishing touches of the face I'm using my favorite iridescent sparkly shimmers on her cheeks and forehead before sealing her off for the final time.
To make Ducky's eyes I made these tiny templates on my iPad and printed them onto some cardboard paper.
I'm then taking my half sphere mold and will use the third biggest one.
Using some UV resin I drop one drop of it into the mold and then place the iris onto the resin upside down like this.
I let it cure for a minute and then add some white UV resin that I mixed with some white resin pigment.
I cure it again for about three minutes and then it's time to demold the eye.
And it's for me!
Oh my god!
This happened because my mold might be a little old at this point and this rhymes but don't worry we're here to rescue it because I can simply use some UV top coat and gloss it over.
And to make the resin spread evenly I can use a lighter and then cure it in my UV lamp.
The first eyes look like this and I think they're really pretty and super shiny.
Honestly, that's not a surprise.
So cute!
The face already looks so much like Docky so I absolutely cannot wait to make her outfit next.
To make Docky's outfit I actually really had to think how to even be able to realize it.
In the end I opted to make an underdress with the white top part and a layered skirt and then basically make a black dress topper separately.
And of course then make the jacket, accessories and shoes.
So how about we start with the underdress first.
First let's make the skirt of Docky's dress.
Since it has three layers and little white strips on them, I decided to cut the strips from white fabric vinyl.
I think fabric vinyl has such a nice and neat finish that I really enjoy using it.
After cutting I just have to weed it out and here you can see I cut three ruffled pieces from blue fabric already and will iron on those vinyl strips onto them first.
I'm just like thinking how expensive all of the machinery for to make these custom dolls.
Especially like resin dolls too.
I'm going to make the bottom top seams of the smaller strips by gluing them around.
As you can see I also pulled in some gathering threads and now gathered the ruffles.
It was a bit tricky to do so but in the end they looked Have you guys seen this like fashion designer that does like pop culture like does like outfits inspired by like movies and TV shows and like cartoons and then she did one from like the Rogers Rabbit the unrealistic expectations of women outfit What's her name?
What's her name?
She did like from Roger Rabbit Jessica.
Yeah Jessica Rabbit.
Have you guys seen that there's like this like YouTuber she does like very little she does like she doesn't upload a lot of videos but she she has like almost a million subscribers from the very few videos that she has uploaded because it's just so good.
I'll show it to you guys later.
It's actually insane.
I saw the short of it and then I watched the video.
So I basically had to go back to the drawing board and try to figure out how to make this skirt look better.
I ended up going with a pleated look instead.
So I prepped some new strips for the skirt and cleaned them up.
Then I sewed the two bottom pleated parts to a tool strip and then attached the top You have to be like a mini like you have to know how to do clothes for this.
And then I pressed the pleats according to the markings on the top pleated part.
For the top part of Ducky's dress I cut this right fabric piece and then attached a little casing to it on top of it.
I sew it, press it, and then stitch it down like this so I can now pull in a little rubber thread through the tunnel that we just created.
If you have trouble threading in threads like this through needles you can just use some tape, attach it to the end of the thread, cut it into a tip, and then thread it through the needle like this.
This is just such a good trick I learned recently that I had to share it with you guys.
And then I just proceed and thread the rubber band into the top.
When that was done successfully I then add a gathering thread onto the bottom part of the top piece and gather it to the length of the blue lower part of the top.
I pin it together and sew it finished sides in.
Afterwards it looks like this and as you can see I already pinned the back parts into the dress as well.
And then I also just sew them on good sides in.
And boom!
A cute cat appeared.
A very important assistant I might say.
Here you can see the finished skirt and now I can take the finished top part of the dress and pin it to the skirt before sewing the skirt and top together finished sides in.
My cat at this point had enough of me in sims.
She was however very interested in the glue cap.
The sewn together dress looks like this and I now just have to pin together the back seam and sew it together about 2.5 inches.
Leaving just enough of a gap for the closure.
The finished dress turned out so good and you can see that even though I have been making dolls for years sometimes I have to remake things in order to make them look better and more accurate.
And that's okay!
We learn from mistakes sometimes.
That's amazing.
Let's make the black topper that Docky wears on top of her dress next.
I prepped the fabric pieces with white vinyl strips already and will now sew together the side seams I'm bringing the cat back.
Where is my kitty cam?
I will now attach the blue lining pieces on which I also iron on some white vinyl strips next.
I place them onto the black parts good sides in and hem them on.
When flapping around the lining parts it really looks like Docky's dress and will close like this in the end.
I already cut and prep the skirt for the topper by cleaning up the bottom seams and attaching a gathering part and will now gather the skirt to match the seam line of the upper part.
And make sure to spread the gathering evenly and fill the skirt and top part together before handing them finished sides in.
At the moment it looks like this and I cursed with a needle to show you guys how to look in the end.
For closure we will be attaching two new snap buttons to the top.
These smart buttons work really nicely for doll clothing.
Last but not least I will be gluing some tiny golden half feet.
It's like designers like manga manga artists and like anime artists.
Dude the design is to make like clothes that look cool not like actually real.
With these final steps the dress topper is done and I'm super happy how it turned out.
It looks so much like Docky's outfit.
I think especially the little details like the blue lining part with the white stripes really make it look very accurate to the original.
Art cares not for gravity.
For Docky's jacket I first take the sleeves that I cut from grey cotton fabric and wrap them by pulling and gathering threads on the top and bottom seams.
I then gather the lower part of them and take these tiny little cuffs that I prepped by ironing them in half and now pin them to the gathered sleeve parts and sew them on.
When done with that the sleeves look really cute already and I can now also gather the top part of them.
I then set them aside for a bit and first will sew on the facing for the raglan collar to the bodice of the jacket.
Of course I fray checked all my fabric pieces to make sure they won't fray before I sew them on.
And after sewing on and steaming the face of the collar it looks like this.
Folding around the collar it will look like this and maybe makes a little bit of sense like that.
And now I can finally take the prepped sleeves and sew them onto the bodice of the jacket with magic.
Last but not least I take my cat and gently push her out of the way so I can show you that I just needed to close the sleeve and side seams of the jacket still.
I pin them together neatly and try to match up all the seams.
I'm just sewing I then put the jacket onto my logo though so I can exactly determine where to place the black ribbon.
I heard that was like the hardest part.
I pinned it before and now careful.
Okay sorry this is off topic cause someone mentioned Kingdom Hearts.
You know how like the Smash Brothers trailer for Sora has no Donald and Goofy?
Cause getting Sora on his own was really hard.
Getting Disney characters in Smash Brothers.
Like okay this is the perfect cut by the way.
The perfect angle for you guys.
But if you notice um if you notice in the Kingdom Hearts Smash Brothers reveal trailer there's no Donald or Goofy at all.
There's no reference to Donald or Goofy.
And even then getting the Mickey Mouse keychain on the keyblade was in itself incredibly difficult to do.
Because like you know Disney was like mmm I don't know.
The horizontal strip is the final touch and will attach to the opposite side of the jacket with a little Velcro on the inside.
The finished jacket looks so cute and I think I'm happy that I was able to make it really similar to the original model.
So now translating 2D designs into 3D is really difficult but it's a challenge that I really enjoy conquering.
Feels like mini cosplay somehow.
Did I actually ever tell you that I used to cosplay back in the day?
Pre Moonlight Jewel times.
Let's make Ducky's boots next.
I cut the boots pieces from blue fabric already and first sewed together the front seam but then just about half an inch.
After sewing and ironing it, it looks like this and I can now proceed to glue around the seam allowance of the upper boot part.
I then take this strip I cut from white fabric covered in fabric vinyl which I also already cleaned up on one side and will now pin it to the boot like this and sew it.
It looks really neat after sewing so I can now flap around the upper boot part like this and make sure it stays in place.
For that I carefully sew with my eye.
I then glue around the back seam allowance of the boot and instead of the zipper totally not because I completely forgot to order some, I will attach an elastic fabric on the back of the boot this time.
I first glue around the top seam of the elastic fabric and then pin it to the boot piece like this.
By my silence!
And glue the rest with contact adhesive.
Afterwards it looks really neat and it worked better than I thought so the next thing I need to do is closing the little bottom seam on the back of the boot.
And after that was done, I turn the boot inside out and finally close the rest of the front seam good sides in.
I turn it inside out again so... Will you see me sponsored by Disney?
You would know.
I now glue it on one of the Nova Dogs to finish the boot.
I cut a cardboard sole from an old cereal packaging and will now glue the bottom of the boot to the bottom of the cardboard sole like this.
Cardboard sole is tough to say.
For the shoemaces I printed these guide boys that grew sculpts and now have to paint the toecaps with them black.
I also prep these tiny buckles I cut from PVC covered in silver vinyl on my laser cutter.
And now take tiny pleather strips and thread them through the buckles first.
As you can see I attach one set of buckle straps to the boot already and will now do the same to the other.
I simply attach them with glue and afterwards can finally glue the upper boot part to the shoe base using some woohoo all purpose glue.
Last but not least I just attach a tiny golden star to the boot as well and with this last step the boots are also done.
I decided to make them from fabric rather than pleather because you can see that on Ducky's original artwork the boots do actually have some wrinkles and I think the fabric choice resembles this perfectly here.
Alright the main part of the outfit is done.
Let's make all of Ducky's accessories.
For her stocking I will be using an actual human tights with stripes like this and cut out the stocking pattern from it.
I then clean up the other seam with glue and then can fold the fabric good size in and sew the back seam of the stocking.
Afterwards it looks like this and this stocking is already done.
For Ducky's choker I first cut this piece from white leather fabric and then take this tiny white lace and glue it to the upper part of the choker.
I will do the exact same to the bottom part of the choker as well and end up with something like this.
Now I carefully glue a tiny satin ribbon to the front of the choker and also add this tiny prepped folded ribbon to the middle of the choker as well.
Oh well I at least tried to.
For the final step I take this tiny golden star and attach it to the middle of the just attached satin ribbon and with a tiny velcro on the back Did you even intend it?
I didn't even know my boots were made of fabric guys.
Everyone said it's all about aesthetic instead of practicality.
That's what I mean.
I didn't even know.
I learned something new today.
I was like whoa my boots are fabric?
To really bond the two components I use a little metal roll.
It's a really nice tool for that.
I proceed and cut the tiny back pieces from the material off cam and now first attach some glue to the back inside of the back to be able to attach the little side strip to it.
Afterwards I attach the front piece in the same fashion and end up with this little bag.
Oh it's a bag!
It's the bag for all my seaming tools.
I don't know you guys know this.
I'm a thief by the way.
I don't know if you guys forgot or not.
A small magnet as a closure.
I glued it to the top part already and now we'll attach the bottom magnet as well with some super glue.
When it was dry the back opens and closes nicely.
Yeah it's like where I put all the tools to do the thieving things, you know?
Like the thief tools.
Yeah.
Doki what's in... what tools does thief use?
You know... thieving stuff.
You know... those tools!
I added these teeny tiny decorations to the back as well with some glue and tweezers and finish off the little leg bag like that as well.
Only one more accessory to make.
The glue gloves!
For these I simply take a folded and cleaned up rectangle cut from jersey fabric and will sew them along the short seam.
Just leaving open a tiny gap for Doki's thumb.
Kind of the same way I made Iron Mouse's gloves back in the day.
I can then simply put them into the hands like this and I really love this easy but nice technique of making fingerless gloves for my dolls.
And with that all accessories for Doki Bird's doll are finally done.
Making accessories is definitely my favorite thing to do because crafting is something that I've been loving ever since I was a kid.
I was 50% done with those gloves.
I'm especially proud of that little leg bag.
Okay so the doll is actually done at this point but for those of you who know me you probably know Best piece ever!
Exactly.
The doll stand.
I have conveniently vectorized the logo already so how about we make that stand now with a final little montage.
Oh it's so pretty!
That's like my logo!
Oh my god!
Wait that's the stand?
Oh I love it!
Like the laser cut of the acrylic.
And with that the doll stand is also done and I can finally assemble the doll completely for the very first time.
And I was absolutely blown away by her how cute she turned out to be.
That's me!
Ducky!
Ducky Bird!
She called me cute!
I just put her together and she is everything.
But I know you're probably dying to see her.
So presentation time!
Yay!
Ducky Bird's rear!
Oh you can barely tell which one is the real Ducky Bird!
Which one is it guys?
Can you tell?
Who will you shoot?
The hair is so long!
Oh my god!
Shoot!
Shoot the right one!
Who's talking?
You'll never know!
It's so cute!
I love how it came out.
Oh my god!
I love the hair!
The hair is so well done.
With all the layers and everything.
It's actually so cute!
And here is my finished Ducky doll and I hope you love her as much as I do.
I also hope her new owner will be super happy with this doll as well.
The new owner?
Me.
I will be going on a tiny little break because I'm actually getting married Oh wait sorry I did not mean to fast forward that part where you get married.
I'm so sorry that was an accident.
Congratulations on the wedding!
Congratulations to the wedding!
Oh my god!
Yeah but I'm getting one of the dolls.
And also like the person who won the auction is getting the other doll.
That's so cute though!
Oh my gosh huge shout out again to Moonlight Jewel.
I love their work.
I remember watching their work before in the past so I was so surprised when she like contacted us saying that she wants to make a doll of me for the charity and like a huge shout out for them.
It was like really nice of them to well they I paid them by the way so it's not like she did it for free because I feel like obviously all the artists need to be supported um and I was so happy that she offered to uh to offer her services for the charity auction and uh I'm so happy to receive one of the dolls!
I get to receive a doll keeper doll!
Alright guys let me show you guys okay the Jessica Rabbit outfit okay Jessica Rabbit uh fashion I was like oh my god I think this one making a Jessica Rabbit okay this oh my god yeah she has like a hundred and forty eight million views on this I feel like you guys must have seen this it's actually insane how talented her uh how talented she is in fashion here
picking an hourglass body
like what the fuck
what the you can do that?
you tell me baby baby please don't go away don't go away like oh my god
how like what she went from an A to a D my ribs hurt my ribs hurt no the thing is she didn't even do so much D for DAB.
Like, look!
All she did was just pad it up!
It was just illusion!
She got some foam and padded the fuck out of her thighs!
And then she got, like, four fucking bras!
Life is a lie.
It's all pads!
I love her stuff.
She doesn't even have that many videos.
But look at how many videos she has in general.
But she already has three... almost three million views!
Because of, like, how talented she is as a fashion designer.
Like, oh my god.
We're going for, like, an extreme look.
Like, look!
Hello, my name is Shay, and I like to make things.
And this week, I am telling you how I made my Jessica Rabbit costume and dress.
Before I can even go for it, I'm vaguely following these two tutorials.
But I'm just gonna kinda wing it.
I should do this!
You're wrapping yourself in saran wrap.
Drawing on two little, like, chicken leg hip shapes.
And cutting it all apart to get your pattern.
It cut a hole in my shirt!
This could be you guys, dragons!
You can add this...
For your butt!
You guys wanna, like, have more ass.
Add, like, these pads behind your butt.
I think once I shave them down...
It's actually gonna be really thick.
I could be thick!
You guys can be thick, too!
No!
Just gonna kinda go for it.
And cut off all the edges.
Until it looks very nice.
No more squats, guys!
Look!
Holy shi- Look at that!
No more squats!
Just add pads!
But I think this is far too extreme.
Even for Jessica Rabbit.
So the hips looked good.
But they were way too big for my body shape.
So I'm doing take two.
This time with two inch foam.
Last time I used four hips.
So this is what it looks like with the corset.
I think it's a good shape.
I think it's still very, like, hourglass.
Without being as crazy as it looks.
Holy shi- Okay.
Okay.
Second one is definitely more natural.
The second one is definitely a lot more natural.
Version one is- Version one is Dexter's mom.
This is literally Dexter's mom right there.
This is- This is a Jessica Rabbit shape.
Now all that's left to do is make the boobies.
Stacking bras and stuffing them with socks is an A- Like an A-cup.
Maybe a B-cup.
But I have very little chest to work with in general.
So for building my chest, I really am trying to, like, push one of them out.
And then build the rest out with padding.
First up is just normal push-up bra that fits my size.
This is from Victoria's Secret.
As you can see, it's not a lot, but it's a little more.
Make it a little bit more.
And then she adds- A second- Oh wait, she puts pads in there?
And then- And then bra number two.
How much does it accentuate?
Oh my god!
Is this how they do that?
Holy shit!
What do we want?
Science.
Damn!
Magic!
What's that?
What's put on the hips?
Magic!
I'm living a fantasy.
Not really!
Again, that is all foam.
All foam.
The power of layers.
Chat, is this real?
Why don't you find out yourself?
Buy four bras.
And go even beyond the super shade.
Now we're going to have our face shades.
And move on to the next step, which is going to be patterning.
For that, I'm going to go outside.
She's like, 40% foam.
Holy shit!
All right, sponsored break.
Okay, I need to like- What the fuck?
Okay, I- I also added boning to this lining layer.
The foam stays on.
And with this chest, I'm going to build this structure and support.
That's what we like, Jessica.
Not going to lie, this is a lot more boobage than I thought it would be.
Oh my god!
This is so crazy.
It looks so nice.
Bro, this is actually crazy.
Is this okay?
It looks like it's falling out because that's kind of how her boobs are.
She went too far!
I kind of love it.
But now that we got the body, now that we got the dress- She kind of loves it, guys.
Okay, and you're like- So this is the sequence- What the hell?
Look at this.
What the fuck?
This is the same person.
The world- This is the same person.
That's actually- This is actually crazy.
She's so talented.
She's actually good at wearing this costume.
That's a free entr- Is this real?
She looks amazing.
Oh my god.
This is the channel, by the way.
She deserves it.
I'm not subscribed.
Guys, now I am.
It's because she says she rarely uploads.
This is the reason why!
Like, whenever she does upload, I like- It just pops up.
Oh, I'm subbing my recommended whenever she does uploads.
Because it's so rare.
Alright, wait, wait.
Okay, Dollifle.
Not Dollifle.
Ah, Nerdforge.
I love Nerdforge stuff.
Nerdforge stuff is like... I love her builds.
But like, I'll show you guys.
I'll show you guys the...
The... what is it?
Which one is my favorite one?
I think my favorite one has to be like her PC builds.
Oh yeah, she turned her PS5 into a Dwarven Kingdom.
Look at this.
I'm Martina, and I have issues.
I've been waiting for my PS5 to arrive, which it did after months.
But now, all I can think about is how normal it looks.
And I've been wanting to do things to it, but I keep telling myself, Martina, there's no need.
I mean, it looks perfectly fine.
Here, let's do that.
Okay, so like, all she... she like, obviously...
Foam is your best friend.
But it's actually crazy that she turned it into some fucking Dwarven Kingdom.
I love Nerdforge.
I love the stuff she uploads.
I'm not subscribed.
Let me subscribe.
I was subscribed!
Okay?
Just not... just not on this channel.
Now I'm subscribed on this channel.
I know it looks like I've done a lot here, but really all I've done is just cut some stairs.
Bossa, thank you for tier 1 sub!
Thank you, thank you!
Way over here was foam, so it's not that bad.
Nerdforge.
Here.
Look at that.
It's so cool.
And now, let's fill all of these little gaps here with some Sculptamold.
It makes so many things with, like, fucking foam.
Like, I mean, like, cosplay for armor was originally done by, like, Nerdforge.
Oh my god, there's this channel I really like that does, like...
They do, like, D&D skits.
I find it really funny.
I'm trying to remember the name.
Does anyone remember...
Does anyone, like, remember the channel name that does, like...
Um...
D&D re-uh... D&D skits?
Trying to remember the name right now.
All that work for a console that has no games.
There's a lot.
Yeah!
Viva!
La Dirt League!
Yes!
That one!
That's one of my favorite channels, too.
I love their skits.
They're so fucking funny.
He's going so fast, he's shaking.
Poor William.
Working so hard.
All right, let me skip a little bit.
Because I've seen this before.
If you guys want to watch more, check out their channel.
But, like, oh my god, the painting, too.
All mixed up now.
Hopefully it's good enough.
Like, wait, okay.
I'm gonna start at the top here.
I need to show you guys the finished product.
This is, like, the electronics and stuff.
Guys, skip, skip, skip.
It's because I watched this already!
If you want to watch, like, the full actual videos, check them out.
Give them a subscribe.
Give them a view.
Give NerdForge a view.
They deserve it.
Holy shit.
Would it not overheat?
Just don't play Cyberpunk.
It's that easy.
But we didn't watch it.
Sad.
Support the original video, nerds!
Exactly.
Not a true reaction!
How dare you, Toki!
Not leech off the entire video!
Where's my real react, Andy?
Pax, thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
Hello everybody!
My name is TokiBae!
I usually stream on the YouTube, but today I'm apparently a failed React Andy.
I'm a fake.
Holy shit.
I love like, she's so good at like crafting and painting and art and everything.
She's so talented.
Fake React Andy.
How dare you not watch the entire video and steal all their content, Toki.
What's the point?
Are people this talented?
It's because they're you.
It's because they actually, they actually like get up from their PC.
Let's try to turn this on and see what it looks like for the first time.
And hopefully everything just works.
Please.
Does it not work like the Xbox?
Like you can turn it on and- Does it not work like the Xbox?
No!
She's almost perfect!
She- Stop.
Okay.
It worked!
Thank you for gifting a tier 1 sub for both Cookie and Kat!
Thank you!
Dude, all the LEDs look so good!
Ho ho ho ho ho!
A fake gamer shake my head.
A long serve.
That is so good!
Wait, I want close up.
Give me the close up!
Oh my god, look at that!
Holy shit!
It looks so sick!
It's like on your fucking desk.
Like, holy shit!
It could overheat!
Just don't play Cyberpunk!
Just play fucking Peppa Pig on this!
Looks so good though.
That's a fucking PS5, guys!
It's oozing lava!
It's gonna overheat!
I love her stuff.
She's like actually one of my favorite crafting channels too.
Okay, yeah, wait.
I'm not gonna watch her stuff, but what was it?
Viva La Dirt League.
I mean, I have 6 million subscribers, but check out- if you like Dungeons & Dragons, I highly suggest checking out this channel.
Because they do a lot of really funny- yes, you can tell that I watch every- every one of them.
D&D stuff.
I- I don't care about the- I don't care about these- the retail stuff.
I just watch the Dungeons & Dragons ones.
But, I suggest checking out their channel as well.
I really like their stuff.
Anyway, subscribe.
Look!
They always pop up in my recommended!
That's why I never- I forget to subscribe!
I always forget to subscribe!
Because they always- whenever they upload new videos, it just pops up in my recommended!
Chat!
I swear!
They just deliver it to me!
Exactly!
They like deliver- deliver the content to me!
So I always forget to subscribe, because it's just there.
It's just there.
Uh, by the way, hit that subscribe button on YouTube, guys.
I'm not just there, guys.
I'm not.
Please subscribe to me as well.
You see, that's how you subscribe to a person, you know?
So you can also, you know, subscribe to someone like me on YouTube as well.
I'm trying to like- there was another channel I really want to show you guys.
But I'm trying to remember, uh, remember the name of it.
Fuck!
It was also a crafter channel, like similar to Nourish Forge.
Um...
I'm trying to remember it.
It's like similar to Nourish Forge as well.
Ah, I can't remember.
I can't remember the channel.
Let me look at my- let me look at how- how my recommended is like now.
Let me see how- how fucked my recommended is like at the moment.
It's not as bad.
It's not that bad, actually.
Thank God.
It's not that bad, chat.
Let's see.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
I mean, there's like other channels that I really like to watch.
Uh...
Oh, this one!
Wait, is this the same one that made the...
Uh...
They made the... the Pokemon...
No, not this one.
There was like a channel that does like Pokemon crafts that I really like.
Let's see.
Pokemon crafts.
I want to see if I can find it.
Oh!
Is this one?
Is it north of the- Oh, north of the border is really nice.
I love north of the border.
Oh my God.
North of the border is more like, um...
really fucked up dioramas.
So...
Um...
I'm scared of scrolling down because I saw what it was down.
But like, it's fine.
It's for like more like...
more like pretty...
dioramas.
Because, um...
If I scroll...
Oh!
Whoa!
But I also enjoy their content as well.
What is that?
Yeah.
Oh yes, I remember!
It's the one with the Halloween ones.
Halloween...
um...
decoration...
DIY.
I think I...
What's it...
That channel?
I'm trying to remember the channel's name.
Was it Wicked Makers?
Oh, I love this channel!
This channel is really good.
This one.
They like, actually made like...
um...
They take like...
Halloween decorations.
And then like make them...
Oh my God.
This looks so good.
They remake them into like...
more like horror themed stuff.
Which is really cool.
They take like super cheap Halloween decorations.
In this video, we are going to build a real catnap animatronic that actually breathes fog.
Or Jamie and Jayne, we bring your favorite monsters to life.
Like this 8 foot tall...
Yeah, thank you for the free subscribe.
Tier 3 for 4 months!
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, those are real.
It's not even like 3D.
Catnap is the main boss in Poppy Playtime Chapter 3.
And it's just... well, just look.
Just look at it.
Like, wait, let me show you guys.
We're going to zoom in.
If you guys want to actually check out the full video, let me subscribe.
I swear!
They are my favorite channels!
Guys, I swear to God, they're my favorite channels.
I used to be subscribed.
I used to be subscribed on a different channel.
I swear!
I hope that's enough space.
Oh, wait, did they make this themselves?
They've done it.
They've done... Oh, wait, they can make... they're starting to make their own animatronics.
Holy fuck.
That's actually crazy.
They used to, like, just repurpose old animatronics for this.
But, like...
But I want to show you guys what's in it.
Wait, I'm trying to, like, show... Should we try it on?
Holy shit.
That shit's so creepy.
I'm still worried that it's too heavy.
Imagine having that, like, as a kid.
Trick or treating.
Imagine trick or treating as a kid and seeing this.
Well, the box works, but the whole thing started to collapse.
We fixed it.
We had to spread the legs out more, and they need to be...
You just want some candy.
Because the pose is so dynamic, it doesn't balance otherwise, but it works.
And look, we can even push on it.
You know what, though?
I hate to say it.
That box is expensive.
That's not DIY.
I took off a whole lot of material, and I don't even know if you can tell, but there's a lot...
That weird cat's back.
Ma!
...work on this for, like, three more days.
And probably still not be happy with it.
But at some point, you have to cull it.
And it has to be done.
Because we have to move on.
Oh my god.
The wires coming out of the eyes.
Okay, we're gonna... I'm gonna zoom past, guys.
I know you guys really want to watch the DIY part, but guys, I want to see the finished piece.
If you want to watch the full video, check it out!
I'm being a fake React dandy.
Holy shit.
I love how, like, they did the sans effect.
Where, like, if you carve the eye deep enough, you can make it so that eye will, like, follow you around.
Toki, please, find work.
We have a free catnip moon.
And this is what hangs off of his zipper pole.
We could just paint it gold, like it is in the game.
But I've always wanted a reason to gold leaf something.
And it seems, like, super extravagant and ridiculous, but only the best for our boy.
I don't even know what gold leafing is.
Well, it's, like, super thin pieces of...
No, you're supposed to eat that!
Oh my god, she's wasting precious gold leaf food!
How would the rich eat?
They can't eat food without the gold leaf.
And now it's gold.
It's true!
In order for rich people to eat, they eat the gold leaf on top.
The rich will starve.
Oh my god, they use, like, the pool noodles.
That's so smart, the pool noodles.
Ugh, the rib cage.
It took me several hours, but I got all of the bad paint.
Off of the nails.
And now I got this cool metallic paint.
We're gonna paint it.
In some ways, building Catnap has gone really well.
We've learned so much since we started making animatronics that we were able to combine it all into this insanely awesome build.
But at the same time, this project has been the hardest thing we've ever done.
The longest hours, the most setbacks...
For only $3,000 a day.
You can starve a...
You can save a starving rich man.
That's how you get better.
To animate Catnap's head, I'm using a huge servo.
Because the head is really heavy, and we need a lot of torque.
A servo is different than a wiper motor.
What's a servo for?
Because I can tell it exactly how to move.
To do that, I'm using this free software called Botango, which is used to animate animatronics.
Instead of writing code, I can just animate in a timeline.
It's super fun.
Anytime I want, I can just make a new animation for Catnap.
And then when it's ready, we export it to the Arduino.
Y'all, we just did a test run.
I can't wait for you to see him in action.
But before we do, we just want to say thanks for watching.
God, I don't like that.
This is... makes me uncomfortable.
Just sitting next to it as if, like, he's friend.
That's so creepy.
I won one for my six-year-old nephew.
Oh, God.
When it's, like, night time, too.
It's so cool, though.
They've done, like, they've actually repurposed, like, they've actually done, like, repurposing, like, Halloween decorations, too.
Wait, let me show you guys.
Like, the spider one.
Like, they made that.
And I'm gonna skip to the end.
We've made a 12-foot spider.
We've made a Minecraft spider.
Like, they've repurposed it.
They repurposed that and turned it into this, which is insane.
It's actually crazy.
They, like, repurposed, like, old Halloween decorations to make, like, actual cool shit.
But I wanna watch...
Then watch the channel!
Wicked Maker!
I'm just showing you an example!
I've seen this video already!
There's no reaction because I've seen it!
I can actually do it!
Toki keeps skipping to the end.
Like, look at that.
That's so cool.
I'm showing my favorite...
Guys, it's not...
You show me your favorite...
It's me showing you my favorite channels.
Humanreactive streamer, you take that back!
It's like I'm showing you my mixtape.
But instead, I'm showing you my favorite videos!
There's actually one where...
They made like Last of Us props too.
I'll show you the short because I can...
Oh my gosh.
Okay, the Last of Us one was really creepy.
I remember watching their Last of Us one.
Liked videos.
Here.
Let's turn this spirit Halloween animatronic into a clicker from The Last of Us.
A giant mushroom bloom has burst out of the clicker's skull.
So first, we're gonna cut a big ol' hole in his face where we want the mushroom to bloom out.
To make the mushrooms, we'll cut a bunch of flowery looking shapes out of EVA foam.
We use a heat gun to bend and shape the pieces and then sculpt on top of them with foam clay to bulk them out and give them some texture.
If you look at the clickers in the show, they're really colorful to contrast with the bleak environment.
To match that look, we airbrushed on some really bright colors and then gave it a brown wash to make it look more organic.
While I was painting, Jay tweaked the animatronic to give it a more scary... It's really cool because the one is the crafter and the other one's the engineer with the electronics, which is really cool that they're working together.
For this, we'll fill any gaps with foam clay and then add lots of details.
I show you my mixtape, but skip until the end of the song.
Finally, I just skipped to where the drop is.
Like, holy shit, that's so cool.
That's so cool.
I just skipped to the drop.
Yeah, they made like, they've done like a lot of stuff, which is really cool.
I love their channel.
as well uh because they do like a lot of like they repurpose like halloween stuff into like actual cool halloween decorations um i mean there's like a stuff okay like because like i don't want to go outside so instead of going outside and like i don't like roller coasters and like animatronics but i love watching like uh people filming attractions so like i don't know if you guys know like attractions 360 so like instead of like actually I just watch videos of other people showing what's in the ride,
so I don't have to go on the ride.
That's not sad!
I just don't like animatronics!
IRL!
Okay, like I said, I don't like animatronics.
I don't like animatronics, but I love watching people make animatronics.
Because I find it really interesting, but I don't like them IRL.
I think it's like, I'm always really scared.
I was like, ooh, what if it touches me?
It just scares the shit out of me.
So I like watching, experiencing it through video, because I'm not actually there.
Usually when I do ride, because I'll give you an example.
I wrote that Harry Potter one from like, what was it?
The...
Oh my god.
The fucking Dementors ride or whatever.
And then like, I closed my eyes the entire time during Universal.
Like, you know the Universal rides?
I closed my eyes, and then I just don't experience it.
And then like, the Dementors ride.
And then I remember like, one of my friends was like, open your eyes!
Oh my god, this is the cool part!
Open your eyes!
And I was like, no.
And then I just rode the entire ride just closing my eyes.
Like, I didn't even open my eyes.
So then I was like, I was like, oh shit, what was in there?
Like, you know?
It's not like I was super young or anything.
I think like, I was like, first year of university or something.
It was like, first year of university.
And it's like, and then they're like, open your eyes!
You gotta see this!
This shit!
Do I see this part?
And then I just closed my eyes throughout the ride.
So I never actually like, saw what anything happened.
I felt it.
I felt like...
I felt the ride.
Like, felt the wind.
And then...
But I didn't...
I don't know...
I don't know visually what it was.
So I just like, looked up on YouTube what the ride was like.
And I was like, oh hey!
Thank god I didn't open my eyes because that shit looks fucking scary.
Thank fucking god.
But I love like, watching videos of like...
Oh, did you guys see the new anim...
Okay guys, spoiler alert.
If you guys...
The new like, Universal Jurassic Park ride...
Looks so cool.
I would never ride on it.
But...
This one's like, in Beijing, right?
The Universal Studios.
I would never ride on it, but it looks so cool.
The Jurassic Road.
Yeah, it's in Beijing.
It's so cool because it's apparently...
It's apparently like, the dinosaur chases you too.
I love looking at the...
Also like, I like looking at the queue.
The...
What is it called?
You know when you're in queue and they have like, all these like, decorations in queue?
There's like, a special name for it.
What is it called?
Because like, sometimes I always...
I do like, the lightning ride.
The lightning ticket.
So...
You can skip...
You can skip the line.
So if you skip the line, you don't get to watch all the...
The...
The decorations from the queue system.
So that's what I like to look at too.
Because I get...
And also you get to like, absorb it instead of like, being rushed in the queue.
It's so cool.
The pre-show!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
If you have the lightning ticket, you tend to skip all the pre-show.
And then you also have to like, you know, you have to walk really fast during the pre-show.
Because you know, you want to get on the line.
Oh my god, it's like we're there.
Guys, it's like we're riding on the attraction right now.
Oh my god.
Yeah, you get to absorb the lore via video.
It's like we're there!
Holy shit, it's so immersive!
Guys, it's like we're just like we're there!
Hands in the air, guys!
Arms in the air!
We're here right now!
We're in Beijing!
This is sad!
What do you mean?
It's so cool.
When it starts chasing you, it's actually so freaky.
So I think it starts...
I would never ride this IRL.
I would never ride this.
It looks really cool though.
Like it looks so immersive.
Really, it seems pretty cool.
Yes, but like what if it touches me?
That's like...
That's like my irrational fear.
I'm like, what if it just touches me?
These dogs look so cool.
Look, it starts moving!
Holy shit, that's so fucking scary!
It just starts chasing you!
Holy fuck!
Oh, even the car moves.
Just like, do you think they don't chase you?
You know, like, I don't try because they don't move, but then it moves.
Okay, then this is just like, I hate the...
I'm not a huge fan of the screens.
I wish they used less screens.
That's my only issue.
I hate how amusement park rides use a lot of screens now.
Oh my god, there's the T-Rex!
I hate the IMAX sentence.
In any amusement park ride.
It just doesn't feel right.
I thought they were going to kiss.
Just like Godzilla and King Kong.
I love the whole debate of why is she running with high heels.
Oh my god, there's Ted.
I want to go to Universal Studios in Beijing.
It looks so cool.
You guys see the new Zootopia?
And in Disney.
Soon Disney will buy Universal.
He's just sleeping chat.
So cool though.
Let's see.
There's a new Zootopia Land in Disneyland.
In Shanghai.
Uh...
I really like the animatronics.
To be fair, I think it's also because Universal and Disneyland in Shanghai and Beijing are newer builds.
So they use newer animatronics and stuff.
And obviously, since it's a newer build, the technology is more high tech.
And Disneyland and Universal in America are fucking old as hell.
So it's super dated.
So like all the newer amusement parks have all the cutting edge technology.
Like...
Even like the...
Apparently...
So like...
Oh, doggy mug purchase.
Jay, thank you for the 5,000 biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
Even like...
Okay.
So...
Is it like...
America Disneyland has the Frozen ride, right?
So America Disneyland has the Frozen ride.
And then...
Hong Kong Disneyland has like the same Frozen ride.
But the animatronics are better than like America's Disneyland.
Because it's using the newer animatronics where it's not using the...
What was it?
The 2D faces.
Where like they use like the projected faces in America.
Because that was the old animatronics.
The newer animatronics actually uses like molded faces for like the Frozen...
Let me see if I can find it.
It's actually crazy.
Hong Kong Disneyland Frozen versus America.
Did anyone...
Oh, there's...
I want to know if anyone made like a comparison video.
Oh, here you go.
Here you go.
This is like...
Well, Disney did it.
Here you go.
You can tell the difference.
It's actually crazy.
Well, Disney did it.
They gave the Elsa animatronic a new face.
This is actually new footage Disney released for Frozen Ever After at Hong Kong.
This is Hong Kong Disneyland animatronic.
It's definitely a major upgrade from that projected face.
Like look...
This is America.
This is Hong Kong.
She came out of Star Trek.
This is the animatronic, that's what I mean.
Because like Hong Kong Disneyland released a new Frozen and the comparison between the two.
No fair.
I swear, I think like America Disneyland, America Disneyland, the Disney World is like the beta test and then after like beta test is over, they're like, all right, let's export this.
It's so bad.
Both figures are programmed with the exact same movements.
And if you look closely, the new animatronic's face matches the exact animation of the projected facial expressions.
And it works even better in my opinion.
Yeah, it does.
This is perfect.
Is it real quick?
Someone help me.
Oh my god.
But I feel like the Disneyland's and the Universal Studios outside of America are a lot better.
Because the technology is better, I feel like.
Because it's newer.
The technology is like newer too.
Oh, and then like when...
Okay, it's so...
It's so freaky.
Okay, wait, wait.
When like...
Because they're using projected faces.
And because they're using projected faces, it breaks down.
Okay, wait.
Elsa animatronic malfunction.
And it's just a black screen.
And it's so weird.
It's so scary.
It's actually really scary.
Let me see if I can find it.
Okay, let's see.
Let's see if I can find it.
It's actually so scary.
Wait.
Wait, wait.
Look at this.
Because the projected face breaks down.
And sometimes like the face...
Oh, and then the Mickey Mouse ride uses these too.
Mickey Mouse animatronic malfunction.
Okay, malfunction.
Okay, I think it's this one, right?
Okay.
I used to...
I watched some of the animatronic malfunction videos.
I love TPM.
Okay, let's see if I can find it.
Let's see.
I think this is this one.
Bear Frozen.
Nope, not this one.
Where is it?
No, that's not...
Oh my god.
Where is the one with the Mickey Mouse breaking down?
I love watching animatronic malfunctions from TPM.
Top 10 Disney animatronic malfunctions.
Is it this one?
Where is it?
Six, five.
Nope.
Not this one.
Wait, is it this one?
No.
Where is it?
TPM.
Don't you betray me right now.
Don't you dare.
Oh, it's this one.
Wait.
I think it's this one.
Okay.
Let me find it.
TPM.
Let's see.
Let me see if I can find it, guys.
This is this one.
Okay.
Pirates.
Figment.
Million Dollar Bunny.
Carousel.
Frozen.
Ever After.
Oh, it's this one.
Okay.
Here it is.
This is the Frozen one I was talking about.
There it is.
The Glitching Projected Face looks exactly like the vertical lines you'd see on a damaged LED TV, only a little more unsettling.
Silent Hill.
Even with these face malfunctions, you'll get something more out of the lines of the character's face going completely black, like this clip of Elsa that was sent in by Vic Hanger on Twitter.
Imagine being a kid if you see that.
Oh, my God.
Imagine being a kid.
She scared at least 10 kids.
That shit's so fucking freaky.
There's like a Disney version.
There's like a Mickey Mouse of that, too.
Oh, my God.
All right, guys.
I'm done showing you guys.
I hope you guys enjoyed.
I hope you guys enjoyed me showing you all some of my favorite channels and videos.
It was like...
It was definitely...
It was a lot of random videos, a lot of random channels.
This is what goes on in my mind.
It's been three hours.
I know.
It's been really fun, though.
I had a lot of fun.
It's not going to be a super common thing.
It's just a little like...
I guess like maybe like once every couple of months, I do something like this.
Be a really bad React Andy.
Sandy, give me five gifted subs.
Thank you.
To be fair.
It's because like a lot of these videos and channels I've seen...
This is literally like some of my favorite channels and videos.
So like I've seen all these videos already.
So it's like watching you dragoons react to it.
You know how like people who like suggest like favorite moments, like favorite TV shows, and they watch your reaction to your favorite part in the show?
That was me throughout this stream.
I was like, oh, my God, this part.
I'm going to look at chat now, see how they react to it.
Like...
But it was really fun to see your reactions to some of my favorite videos and channels.
Phoenix, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you.
Yeah, chat reacts to.
It's not streamer reacts to.
It's chat reacts to.
You were the React Andy all along.
Ben, thank you for the reset for three months.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm farming you guys for reactions chat.
But yes, I had a lot of fun.
I had so much fun showing you guys some of my favorite videos and channels.
And I hope you guys had a lot of fun too, everybody.
For those who are new here, my name is DokieBird and I usually stream on YouTube.
So please check me out on YouTube and subscribe to me over there and actually be a real fan.
Not like me because I accidentally exposed myself as not subscribing.
To some of my favorite channels.
But you'll do better, right?
You guys will do better than me.
Thank you for a thousand bitties.
Thank you.
Thank you for the tier one sub.
But I had so much fun though.
Celeste, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you.
But yes, if you guys want to follow me on Twitter, exclamation point Twitter.
I usually tweet out when I'm doing Twitch streams because my Twitch streams are very, are like sort of random.
But I let people know in advance on Twitter.
So please follow me over there.
If you want to support me via other means, please check out my merch, exclamation point merch.
And support me by buying merch as well.
Anyway, guys, I had a great time with everybody.
I'm going to head out now.
And as always, everyone stay hydrated.
Pause to check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stood up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.